[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello ich bin phil spencer
we at team xbox are excited to be back
at gamescom to celebrate gaming with our
fans from all over the world
whether attending the show or watching
from home
fans in germany europe and around the
world can expect a little more insight
into some of our previously announced
games coming to xbox in the next 12
months
we're excited to continue building a
community together and bringing the joy
of gaming to everyone on the planet
from all of us at xbox dankeshen and
welcome to gamescom 2022.
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hello everyone it's been
three long years but today we are
finally back in hello germany to bring
you all things gamescom and it feels so
good to be back for the next six hours
we'll be bringing you in-depth
discussions with the creators of some of
this year's most anticipated games and i
think these guys are excited
that's right charlie today we'll be
talking with the brilliant minds
responsible for a plague tale requiem
it's age of empires sea of thieves
minecraft legends microsoft flight
simulator pentiment high on life lies of
p
grounded under the waves planet of lana
and gunfire reborn and listen i cannot
tell you how good it feels to be back
here surrounded by fans and developers
and not just talking through a computer
screen after all of these years am i
right everyone
that's right
it feels so great to be back and to be
bringing such brilliant games along to
games come with us if you're watching at
home we want to hear what you're excited
about so as we go through the show use
the
xbox gamescom to join the conversation
now let's get into the content and i'm
going to ask my colleagues to clear the
runway so we can welcome the creators of
flight simulator to the stage but before
we sit down with the team what a better
way to celebrate gamescom than with an
entrance to the city from the flight
simulator directly enjoy and huge boss
this has to be one of my favorite clips
and based on the video you just saw our
next two guests landed here at cologne
mesa in germany to talk all things
airborne i'm super thrilled to introduce
you the head of microsoft flight
simulator jack nyron and also the ceo of
a solo studio sebastian vlog thank you
so much for joining us thank you so much
maxie it's great to be back here at
gamescom
beautiful cologne and in person
thanks so much for having us thank you
and i heard you brought something
special with you today yes we did we we
thought we have to rise to the occasion
and do something special and we we had
to come up with something new so for the
first time we're doing something called
city update which essentially means we
made five new photogrammetry cities here
in the area and we have a trailer so
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this looked incredible yeah i think i
even saw
five soccer stadiums i definitely tell
people i'll be cologne i wonder if you
have any cologne fans you're crazy
look guilty i'm a big buddhist [ __ ] fan
and my my favorite club is after kern
so
so happy to put it into a video
but
i hear it i hear it still here but yeah
really incredible amazing thank you now
photogrammetry is awesome so just to
explain we flew all this last year
um so basically we have planes flying
really low taking a photograph a second
episode of millions of photographs out
of that we built these 3d cities and so
it's it's beautiful and i hope i hope
the germans love it a little bit but
that's not the only thing that we did
for germany
so when we go into a region we try to do
a regional plane we call those local
legends it's a plane that is not that
well known in the world but it's known
in the country so last year for gamescom
we actually launched the youngest hu 52
which is my personal favorite plane and
for this year we said what are we going
to do to top this and we we are we are
taking the sort of the father of the
younger 252 it's the youngest f-13
which was the first metal
transport plane in the world so it
actually started airlines that one and
um yeah so we actually have a trailer so
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
that trailer the music it really you
you're just bringing a beautiful piece
of history to life so thank you so much
for that and i'm wondering when you are
choosing a plane like the yonkos f13
like what is the process like to make it
as authentic as possible i'm assuming
you can't just like travel back in time
and talk to the german engineer hugo
juncker himself
time travel step it's a new feature we
need we need to put that in the flights
no seriously so it's a ton of research
the first thing we do is are there any
surviving aircraft so this plane is from
1922. um and we looked and there are
pieces
so we first contact all the museums
where the pieces are and um so in this
case the german museum deutsche mission
in munich has an original cockpit they
had it in storage we told them what our
plan were they're like we'll bring it
out of storage so we scan that in down
to the millimeter and then um they also
had a replica so we've scanned the
exterior and then there's a company the
yoga's company celebrated the hundred
year anniversary of this plane just
recently and they built three replicas
so we talked to that team as well and
they let us scan all the new instruments
and they have people who fly that so
they give us feedback on the flight
model and everything to make sure that
it's perfect so it takes a ton of people
but it's great fun
so does that mean when you for example
decide on a new plane to bring back you
have a dedicated internal team that will
look after it or do you bring some
outside people in as well we bring
outside people in so this particular
plane is actually made by a german
engineer a software engineer his name is
oliver moser and he works with the
german museum and a whole bunch of other
people to really get it right uh and and
the curators of those museums they live
those planes that's what they do in
their life right so they know everything
about everything we can ask them any
questions so
that that's the process with all with
all the aircraft this new aircraft zap
is actually oftentimes traveling yeah
yeah uh just last summer we visited a a
school to fly on the gimbal cabrio g2
when we when we do an aircraft we make
it extremely realistic
we go capture audio data flight data
visual data
and we test the aircraft with engineers
from the manufacturers or even test
pilots
and i mean that sounds incredible but
even more incredible is
flight sim is literally turning 40 this
year like it's i'm 38 i can't even
believe there is a game that is older
than me no but um it's really amazing
it's a milestone and you announced that
the xbox bethesda showcase that there
will be a 40th anniversary edition um
before we dive into that one
what does it feel like to run
microsoft's longest gaming franchise do
you have any key elements that you can
share yeah i mean it's it's like we're a
little bit in awe right we're living
history we feel very
um thankful we always say we're standing
on the shoulders of giants
bruce artwork made the first slides that
we invented the genre we tried to stay
very true to that fundamental vision and
i would say that what stands out to me
is the fans
we talk to them all the time there's
people that have been blitz flights in
for 40 years so they're in there in the
80s they know everything and they're
very vocal and active and that's what
makes it fun
when you're talking about the community
what have they been asking for for the
40th anniversary ah yeah so they started
they have a lot of requests about two
that stood out for us was helicopters
and gliders and sep and his awesome team
at the sobo did a bunch of work so just
talk about that a little bit yeah so uh
helicopters and gliders they both are
very specific and they require a lot
more accurate simulation of the airflow
around the aircraft
so for example for helicopters
they we have the gimbal cabrio g2
we simulate a thousand surfaces
of the helicopter instead of just one
which was the previous helicopter model
and we have to simulate also the airflow
around the helicopter
because the rotor
is what makes the helicopter fly and it
pushes the air downwards so it creates
very complex airflow movements
to make it easier for
people to understand how this worked
we have added a visualization so people
can turn on and off
a tool that allows to see how the air
flows around the helicopter
so and you see the the air really uh how
the creates water is and how it creates
turbulences around the helicopter
and so there's very important effects
that uh account when you fly a
helicopter one of these is translational
lift
translationalist lift is when the
helicopter goes forward uh it's easier
for it to catch the air and climb up and
we actually flew the gimbal in july and
it's very strong the effect when you fly
you go forward and as soon you go
forward you get a lot of lift and it
really goes up
yeah another effect we have is the
ground effect uh when the propeller the
the rotor pushes the air down it's uh
for the helicopter like climbing a
ladder that always goes down and when
you go closer to the ground the air is
blocked by the ground it goes down
slower and the helicopter can it's more
efficient than climbing up
does that make just a question like
because you said july and it's very hot
that makes a difference right oh yeah
yeah uh the gimbal g2 has enough power
to easily climb vertically when it's
cold
but in july when we flew it was it was
100 degree fahrenheit and we couldn't
even go up vertically we had to go up
forward
yeah and another thing you said um it
sounds very dangerous that's like
this blade flapping i'm sorry oh yeah i
don't i don't have any aircraft
knowledge this deep but it sounds like
it's a it's a baby bird's first fly i
don't know almost it feels like wings so
the helicopter physics is really very
complex we had to push it up from 100
hertz to a thousand hertz so just to
capture a rotor going around
because it spins so fast and flapping is
when when the helicopter wants to go
left it needs to push on the left side
so the the rotor goes up and down and up
and down it actually resonates when it
turns around but everything is offset by
about 90 degrees because it's also soft
right it takes it takes time for the
rotor to bend and push the helicopter on
the other side
uh one important effect is the
groundwater the vortex effect with the
with the ring vortex when when the
helicopter spins
uh when the helicopter rotor spins it
creates a vortex when you go down it
goes into its own its own airflow its
own vortex and it's it's very hard for
it to climb at that moment
that i love these deets i could i could
talk forever about this but i think the
most important question now is could you
explain a little bit um what is the
difference between a glider and all the
other aircraft
yeah very important a glider
most of the guides don't have a way to
go up in the air so they need to uh they
need to find a way to take off
so they have a either a tow plane or
they will have a winch which is going to
launch them into the air
and and once you're up there if you want
to stay in the air you need to find
places where the air goes up
and so uh
experienced pilots will know where to
find updrafts but we added a system for
anyone to see them in the environment so
you can see the air flowing up
and it's it's easier to find where that
happens
and uh
the the the pilots can then fly in the
environment go up it
it also the glider has a very long glide
distance but when there's updraft it can
stay in the air for hours basically as
long as there is sunlight and as long as
it heats up the air
and and uh it makes it yeah it makes it
very fun you can fly glide along uh
mountains
on the hills where everything is south
exposed goes up and so it makes it a
very uh
very complex and enjoyable experience
with its visualization you spend clearly
a lot of time in this um have you shown
this like to any pilots or other people
outside
yeah for example the helicopter
simulation we showed that to uh
instructors of the same helicopter model
and they flew with it compared it to the
real-life helicopter
they were super impressed by how
realistic this is how it reproduces
exactly uh the flights of the helicopter
and all the different conditions
and for the for the gliders we're
actually working with the studio called
flight sim studio that they are they're
hell they're glider pilots they know
tons about that so yeah we look for
experts just to get back to make it
right
so since the instructors were so
impressed um would you think that the
community would be equally impressed
yeah we've been showing this a little
bit the visualization tools and all that
and you know in the past like our last
place it was called fights m10 it was
basically a helicopter was a box with a
single point
now sepp has thousands of points the
physics simulation is out of this world
nobody's ever seen anything like this
before and they are over the moon
so they can't wait they can't wait so i
loved hearing about helicopters and
gliders and planes do you have any other
aircrafts coming to the 40th anniversary
edition yeah so there's actually a big
the third big question from the
community was a it's called true to life
airliner that means you know airliners
are huge incomplex they have thousands
of buttons and true to life means that
every button does something so we work
with the team they're called indie
builds they're experts they're doing an
a310 airbus
and i think the community can't wait i
mean those things are typically just pay
aware and we now put it into the
basement i think it's like a gift like
the whole idea of the 40th anniversary
edition is like it's a box of chocolate
here's some gifts i like chocolate i
like chocolate what i like more it's
actually trailers do we have one we do
so just to speak to the rest of the so
we also want to celebrate aviation you
know aviation when you think about it
it's 120 years and we have 40 of that so
it's like let's let's connect those
things together so we picked some of the
classic planes from the 1903 wright
flyer and we spent like five decades all
the way to 1940s and we do have a
trailer for that and let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it looks like we have a few more
surprises in this trailer and we have
some planes in there that we didn't see
before that is exactly true so there is
a
curtis jn4 jenny that's from 1915 it's
actually the plane they made thousands
of these and it's the plane that
everybody in like literally america and
also in europe trained so that's when
the air airplanes really took off around
that time and that plane is at the
center of all that then the next plane
we added was the the grumman goose 21 a
beautiful plane it's sort of it's famous
because it shuffled hollywood famous
people to catalina island and places
like that with water planes so it's
lots of luminaries so that and a lot of
them are left because you know honestly
wealthy people had those planes and then
at the very end i don't know if you saw
that that huge plane that's the huge
edge for hercules it's better known as
the spruce ghouls so that's how it uses
um you know he was a big ambitious guy
so he said i'm gonna build the biggest
plane ever made and forever and ever
this was the biggest plane in the world
and it only flew once for 20 seconds and
we worked very closely with the museum
there's a museum in oregon called
evergreen museum it's part of the
smithsonian organization um and we they
have the plan so they let us in there
take photographs they gave us tons and
tons of feedback and they're so happy
because this is going to be the first
time the spruce schools really flies
that's gotta be cool that is really
really amazing i'm not sure if that's
the one but i want to touch a little bit
on the legacy and maybe this is some of
the moments that captured this
four years of flight sim what has fans
coming back to the flight simulator like
every day
uh to me i mean we talk about this as a
team all the time to me it really is
like the the fundamental
truth is that the the flying is a human
dream and it's been a human dream for a
long time i honestly think people looked
at the sky looked at the birds and said
man you know i wonder what that looks
like and the dream when bruce artwork
started all this the dream was go
anywhere look at anything see it from
that very unique perspective of flying
and we stayed true to that the franchise
stayed true to that and i think that
dream is very much alive and still
shared and now with this new version
like it used to be we didn't have enough
data we couldn't really the planet
didn't really look like the planet when
we started this we had four petabytes of
data which is four thousand terabytes a
lot
and uh in the cloud so we now suddenly
could actually show every
house every building we have 1.5 billion
houses
we have four three three or four
trillion trees so we have literally
every house and every tree on the planet
and everything looks right so what
people are doing now is what i call
digital tourism so that's there was
always people interested in planes and
now people are also interested in the
world and let's just look at everything
and visit it and i think that's a new
dimension that we've added that that
brings in new people to this hobby and
it's a beautiful thing
so sebastian what's your experience in
this i mean aviation is so rich it's a
120 years of constant innovation there's
so many different things to discover so
many planes so many aircraft so many
helicopters
it's just very vast to explore and then
the playground is the planet right it's
it's huge you have so many cities
millions of cities you have so many
countries you can go travel prepare
travels
there's just so vast there's way more
than 40 years of stuff to discover
i have one question for you both because
i want to know
which is your favorite city to fly over
that's a very good question so i really
like sydney all right because i've never
been and i want to go because i saw it
in flights i'm like and i actually
landed everywhere under the bay bridge
or whatever the
whatever the bridge is called awesome i
need to go in real world yeah what's
yours the best it's gonna be san
francisco san francisco we've been there
we've been mine is ceo like i've never
been there korea like i want to fly over
that i spent a month in south america
i've never been to south america i flew
around for a month i now have a sense
what suriname looks like i had no
earthly idea right so but i it actually
sort of this itch to travel especially
during the pandemic i couldn't go
anywhere
that really helped me and it really
brings the planet closer to you it's
great it does and there's nothing like
taking your halo pelican and hover over
your own street in munich i can just
recommend that um so the important
question of course when will fans be
able to hop into the carpet to take off
with the 40th anniversary edition yeah i
mean so the 40th anniversary edition is
really is releasing on november 11th so
that's three months from now it has it's
a full box of chocolate so we talked
about some planes so it has 12 new
planes it has 14 heliports 10 air glider
airports it has four classic airports we
didn't really ever talk about yet like
flights have always used to start in
chicago on meg's field that airport
closed we didn't have it in our original
sim now we have it there's others coming
there's new missions we're bringing
missions back from the old sim so i
think it's a true celebration of the
franchise and um and this in case people
don't know the 40th anniversary edition
is in fact free for people who are on
xbox uh on game pass and who or already
owned flights well i love celebrations i
love everything that is free so i can't
wait to hit the skies with this 40
anniversary edition of flight simulator
thank you so much jack thank you so much
sebastian for coming here and as you
always say at the end of your trailers
the sky is calling
yeah see you in the skies
thank you so much thanks thank you
so before we hear from
before we hear from the folks behind
planet of lana let's visit a spooky
reimagine of boston in 1925. in this
uniquely mccaber mystery you inhabit the
bootstraps of a dashing detective
investigating a chilling murder with the
demon as your partner it's the classic
kind of good cop demon cup routine it
has full of puzzles an eye-catching art
style great action gameplay and a plot
that will have you at the end of your
seat check out the new trailer for this
wonderful unique looking adventure it is
the last case of benedict fox
[Music]
that's him
my father
secrets did he take to his grave
glad you came back
my beautiful canvas
[Music]
your father's ego has suffered more than
the anticipated
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
benedict
coming up next is flake tail weak rim
but first charlie is standing by with
our very own erin greenberg and i have a
very special question for erin can you
show us your nails
just like gaming is for everyone so is
getting your nails done and the xbox
controller colors thank you maxie that
was so great and now i've learned about
shellac it's a whole process right and i
feel like i'm in a secret beauty club
now or something he really is i do hope
you take these techniques back with you
to seattle maybe phil next at trends
maybe i'm in who's next let's do this
let's get the xbox sales trending
absolutely we're going to do it right to
the here and now
how does it feel being bagger games come
after three years and surrounded by this
incredible community this is like a
dream come true yeah you know for us at
xbox like it always starts with the fans
it's about the fans always yeah these
are the most memorable moments of all
the years we love the games we love the
products but the memories are great with
fans are ones that last forever and
finally after three years to be back
here it's really special it really is
talking of memories do you have any
favorite ones and you can't say talking
to me three years ago
that was great
so no i would say listen we have done
fan fest that's always been kind of the
highlight of gamescom fans here in
germany fans from all over europe come
we've done parties on boats on the rhine
yeah we've done this on a boat and so
this year you know we have a big booth
here at gamescom we did a a really great
after hours event just for fans last
night and it was fun because he started
giving out prizes and then throwing
controllers into the might have thrown a
few things sorry
it turned into like a sea shanty fast
and fans were singing sea shanties and
it was like
just the joy and love we give for our
fans it just warms our heart and uh we
miss this yeah absolutely and for those
who can be here this year what can they
expect from us on the booth at gamescom
well we have tons of playable so i mean
start maybe with pentiment so you know
obviously josh sawyer and the team
obsidian have been working on this
incredibly rich narrative adventure
taking us back to 16th century bavaria
so of course we had to launch it right
here in bavaria fans are loving it um
that's coming out in uh in november
we've got new age of empires four
updates yeah we do new tips coming those
are also free for h4 players
we've got some great partner titles here
liza p yep uh so if you were looking for
like that pinocchio meets bloodborne
meets game pass exactly a punishing
childhood game for everyone yes it is in
the like 18 plus sections the secret bit
over there yeah
last case of benedict fox yes that was a
big highlight from showcase um and i got
to meet the team from plot twist they're
here from poland that's also nice
there's a lot of developers here that
are creating games for xbox and for pc
and for the ecosystem and to get to meet
those teams it's also super special and
then of course for grounded the full
release september 27th we have a uh a
giant 17 foot over five meters wide
brood mothers and i'm told that that's
to scale as well versus in-game that's
how big she is yes so yeah we're having
a great time the boots filled with games
filled with fans and that's what
gamescom is about yeah and it's just
nice to finally be back here and let
people get to experience some of that
magic again nothing beats in person 100
couldn't say about it myself so thank
you so much aaron coming up next we'll
get an inside look at the much
anticipated a plate tail requiem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we knew it i knew it
all right
move quick
far across the sea
an island calls
the thing never stays nice it always
sounds bad
things aren't always nice you can change
them
no
the way we always do
how far will you go to save the ones you
love
a plague tale requiem picks up a few
months after the end of innocence
right around the first days of summer
amecia and hugo are headed south along
with their mother beatrice and the young
alchemist lucas
reaching places still spared by the
devouring plague the raging wars and the
rabbit rats that are running rampant in
the north
is that affair
beneath the warm sun of 14th century
provence
the darunes are almost able to enjoy a
normal life
but for a recurrent dream that hugo has
been having of a mysterious island that
calls him
it's a two teeth island
how come nobody noticed that
disappearance maybe nobody cares
maybe
one day the immaculate illness that's
been dormant inside hugo awakens
and the dreaded living nightmare begins
again
in the wake emacia finds herself with no
other choice but to trust her brother's
dreams and head further south towards
the elusive island
before he's consumed by the terrible
macular affliction the bite yes
they took the arena down they let them
die here
starting all over again
her mind is made up
she will find a cure in what dreams and
prophecy may hold get used to it with
almost no one they can trust this is
your life now emicia and hugo must
traverse land and water as restless
forces stand against them
after the events of last winter the
mesia is hardened
experienced and when backed against the
wall can be surprisingly resourceful
with several new tricks up her sleeve
she is now able to freely choose between
striking from the shadows or unleashing
hell with a variety of equipment and
tools
hugo wants more than ever to help his
big sister and not hinder their progress
the macula within him is a double-edged
sword that has deepened his connection
with the rats perhaps
they can feel people's blood
this powerful ability can decimate
entire squads of soldiers
but takes a severe toll on hugo every
time he uses it
what's wrong
thankfully their journey brings not only
hardship but also unexpected friends
these colorful characters help the
darunes carry their terrible burden it's
not my first time while offering unique
skills and resources to bring them
closer to their elusive games
[Music]
and hugo the road ahead will test the
limits of what they can endure on all
levels
and just how far they're willing to go
reaching the island is only the first
step to truly understanding the terrible
affliction that stricken their family as
the lines between reality
fantasy and fate dissolve
keeping it together and finding the cure
to save hugo
will be nothing short of a miracle
but emesia has hope
and hope is the last thing lost
others are burned in it
if you kill be ready
a plaguetale requiem releases october
18th on xbox series
[Music]
wow what a journey i don't know about
you but i've been eager to get back to
the rats infested france of the 14th
century which is a sentence i never
thought i'd say and it's in part thanks
to this guy over here kevin chateau game
director for a plague tell requiem
releasing this fall kevin thank you so
much for joining us today thanks for
having me i'm super happy to be here
it's such a good day so we're going to
dive right into that trailer as it
mentioned this is the follow up to the
smash hit innocence so i was wondering
if you can catch us up to where emicia
and hugo are up to now so um the game
takes place in the fourth 14th century
south west france they are they they
came from the southwest
but they had to flee because of the
advent of the first one
and so we joined them six months after
the event of the first one on the road
uh they are arriving in the province so
south east france and we are gonna
explore this region and also a bit of
the mediterranean sea
lovely so for those who haven't or
people are waiting to jump right into
requiem i should say but maybe they've
not played innocence um would you say
it's recommended reading is it important
to go back i'm certain you'll say it is
but what do you think for new fans no of
course
yeah absolutely no no it's um
[Music]
we have a re
not rebooted but rethink everything in
the game so
it's a brand new game we have done
everything to
onboard everyone joining uh a collected
universe so even if you haven't played
the first one you can jump in it it
would be good for you absolutely so i
was actually wondering if you could talk
a little bit about the um the sort of
accessibility and the onboarding that
you've done and what you had in mind
during development what some of the key
changes coming to requiem especially for
those who loved the original as well
so then um there's a lot of new things
of course so you've seen it in a trailer
um in terms of gameplay it's much more
wider bigger
much more open than the first one was
yeah i picked up on that actually yeah
yeah it was quite narrow the first one
so we were able to open it even further
and offer new tools to amicia like the
daily crossbow she has now
oh the knife she can use quite the
arsenal she's got with her now yeah yeah
and then it's it's quite different for
us for her because now she's using war
weapon
it was not something she was doing in
the first one
so she she's ready to deal with death
much more than very ready deal with
death and deal out death by the looks of
the trailer so you mentioned the word
new a lot and i think it's important to
point out that this is the new console
generation that we're working with at
the moment so um what kind of shiny
current gen features can we expect to
see in requiem so there's many things
again um the first one that comes in my
into my mind is uh we have uh pushed the
fascial expression the democap even
further it was a brand new thing for us
we had no mockup on the first one so we
build up our studio we've learned new
new ways to work so we've improved this
aspect of the game and visually it's
much more stunning than the first one
was
um we've um
we wanted a larger game as i was saying
but uh we needed then more light because
the light is a key element of our
gameplay i love the way every new thing
brings its own problems that you have to
overcome yeah so we have
a much more wide area so it means more
light light is very uh expensive in
terms of performances for the game so it
was a big challenge but also of course
wider space we need
to fill it with something yeah
so we jump up from 5 000 to 300 000
right on the screen that's a lot of rats
to begin with so sorry say that one more
time that's five thousand to three
hundred thousand yeah that's it
are you not okay that's a lot of rats to
put in the video game
well i was gonna say well thanks to all
of those rats it does mean that um when
we say that emission hugo have been
through quite a lot i think it's a
little bit of an understatement
especially now um and at the end of the
day they're actually still children if
there are anyone out there who didn't
know that much background from the story
so um how do you go about showing their
relationship in an authentic way after
everything that they've been through
together it's about to do that because
they've been through a lot they have
experience
they were almost
dead sometime and a lot of people around
them
died
so they have to grow up be much more
mature than uh what they should be at
their age um
it's super hard to build up a
story and convey a
convincing dialogue
for children
fortunately the team is quite old now
and uh yeah
age is about a number
but um and we a lot of us have children
so we we can
be inspired by them and and try to feel
the best way to convey uh children
emotion to the players it must be a very
difficult one to do though i mean as a
parent myself like i can only reasonably
say that i hope i never see my children
go through whatevs in that game so
what's that sort of like to go yeah
we're reflecting the childlike
experience in the game but
also committing terrors to them yeah
this this is something we have no
no inspiration from to take from because
yeah again you don't want to be inspired
by that too
of course no
yeah well fair enough um we're going to
focus a little bit now specifically on
amisha uh as in innocence we saw her
wielding a crossbow
she's way more prepared she's way more
confident dangerous and all round i
think you'll agree a bigger all-round
hero to hugo so how do a tactics change
in requiem and what does that mean for
the people playing as her so um yeah as
the prepared is the is the right word
she's
she's ready she don't want uh just only
to survive or to escape she's ready to
fight if she needs to absolutely but
she's not forced to
so the player can choose the way you
will approach this oh interesting okay
so you can go
full stairs if you want you can go full
combat everything is still there from
the first one so but right now you can
choose to approach a situation the way
you want
so it's not that only the space that is
wider but also the way you will approach
things yeah and by full combat yumi i
mean we saw some stuff from the trailer
like you all out of combat right yeah
yeah you can burn people you can use the
crossbow to kill them instantaneously or
you can use the knife to silently kill
them it's all there it's absolutely all
there and i think that all comes
together and making the experience so
much more cinematic
which i want to talk about now because
the other thing that's so fantastic
about the title is the voice acting and
i think that becomes essential when you
want to convey emotion so i'd love for
you to share a little bit of insight
about the development process working
with the the voice actors and getting to
the voices of the emotion that we hear
in that trailer
so it's funny because it's something
that people don't really know but when
we are working on the game for several
years
we don't work with voice actor
instantaneously so for like two or three
years we work with a text to speech so
robot voices
and for an emotional game it's a bit
hard and it takes you out a little bit
yeah it's like when you use your
smartphone it's a flat voice
with no emotion no punctuation nothing
that makes really sense so it's really
out good to keep your focus on the story
sometimes to understand what is the
purpose of sequence
it's yeah after 16 hour of breakthrough
you're like
i think i don't get the story at all
interesting that it changes that much i
will say first of all i would love to
see that version one day it does sound
wonderful um so do you wanna what was
the process like working with the voice
actors so when the voice actor arrived
it changed everything uh because we were
able to work again with charlotte
macberle and uh
legend
which were the actor for amiso hugo from
the first one
and
we were so in love with their acting it
was a game changer for us to have them
back in the game
um
they
when they arrive their voices arrive in
the game uh the game change uh i was
gonna say imagine it's a little bit of a
chicken and egg situation with voice
acting who informs the character is it
you guys designing the character or does
the voice act to come in and actually
completely change the scene actually
it's both yeah we prepared everything
and they react to what we've wrote and
they say no i think amicilla should say
it like that a bit more like that so we
change that on on the fly with them and
adapt the game sometimes to their their
feedback to make it even better and even
more accurate they are still children
and we are not anymore so i love that
they have their own feedback as well
it's their character right it's it's
their character that they're conveying
so big love for them to feed him back as
well right well lastly for anyone who is
watching this segment out there who
can't wait to play requiem in october
which by the way is day one on xbox game
pass and maybe you're not here in
gamescom as well i'd love to know what
you would like to tell the folks at home
about requiem so we're super glad to
have it day one on that on the day
on game pass because it means that a lot
of players will be able to try the game
and to give us feedback because i really
want to see their reaction you know i
can't wait to see that we've built up
the games in several years and we write
up this big story and i really want to
see people reaction to that and the
community have been really close since
the first title as well yeah yeah and
it's thanks to them that we were able to
do the sequels so uh um yeah we're super
loved letter to them yes by the courier
device of rats three hundred thousand of
them to be nice three hundred
thousand rats of love
absolutely fantastic well thank you so
much for joining me i'm a massive fan of
series and i cannot wait to get my hands
on it thank you again yeah thanks so
much for joining us but when it comes to
self-care you can't be a re-watch of the
disney classics right i know i certainly
can't yet in recent years many of us
have also sought comfort in virtual
worlds millions of players have found
solace in games that allow us to
customize islands build unique homes and
share virtual spaces with friends when
we can't actually see them in person our
next trailer builds on that idea and
takes it to a whole new world so to
speak here's an all new look at disney
dreamlight valley
hello everyone i went on a wonderful
adventure today in dreamlight valley and
i want to share it with you
it started with my favorite song on the
radio don't you just love when that
happens it put me in the best mood ever
so i picked out my look for the day i
was in the mood for something
adventurous and i had the perfect outfit
i was feeling a bit creative so i added
a little touch of magic to my look and
then i was off
i made my way to shae remy for brunch i
love cooking with remy i was feeling
some mickey waffles with jam but it
turns out we were fresh out of fruit
raspberry jam is my favorite so i headed
up to the forest of valor to pick some
and while i was there i heard a sound
from the frosted heights bio
but i just couldn't cross the bridge
i'll have to adventure back there to
check it out my stomach started to
rumble so i headed back over to the
plaza and we were ready to cook i always
learned something new with remy there
are so many recipes to try to create the
perfect disney themed meal
ah here we go
i even whipped up an extra and shared it
with kristoff
after brunch the weather was just so
perfect that i couldn't resist going for
a walk and some shopping while looking
in the windows of scrooge mcduck's
general store i ran into scrooge himself
he asked for my help spreading the word
around town about his shop of course i
said yes so i headed over to my crafting
table whipped up a few signs and placed
them around town i was exhausted after
so much excitement and i just felt like
relaxing a bit so i decided to move my
house over to dazzle beach to watch the
sunset when i set up my house i noticed
a strange pillar merlin had quite a
story to tell about it i put up the
perfect hangout spot and i invited ariel
to hang out because
happy moments are always better when you
share them with friends
it really was a perfect day in
dreamlight valley
pre-order disney dreamlight valley now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ahoy there welcome my name's adam park
and i'm head of brandon license in a
rare and i am joined today by three
members of the cf3 coup see a three crew
i mean
yeah it's kind of weird
so
i'll go along the road so we've got joe
needs executive producer on sea of
thieves we've got mike chapman who's our
creative director and then we've got joe
who is our senior community manager so
how is everyone
excited tired everything all of the
above that wonderful mix you get at
events yeah yeah feeling the buzz of the
live show yeah
the energy so awesome i mean it is our
first official show since
2019 yeah so how is it actually being i
mean i'm sure everyone's asking the same
question but how is it back at a show
with people
overwhelming but in the best way right
like it really is like it's just
the the passion the excitement of buzz i
think that we all have coming to a show
like this right and and and kind of
meeting the fans but then giving back to
us from everybody that we see it's just
like it's it's incredible like we've
brought so much money of the team here
we've got about 13 i think with us like
um and
because it's just so valuable bringing
people to shows getting that buzz
getting that energy that you just take
back to the studio to kind of just pour
into more sea of thieves basically yeah
absolutely 2019 but it feels so much
longer yeah but the first live show has
seen for us since 2019 so exactly what
joe said feeling the buzz from the fans
and we get to take that energy back to
the studio to keep making this year and
so joe this is your first official sea
of thieves event yes first official
cfp's event and first gamescom general
it's amazing like obviously we had a
little taste of this end of july with
software yep and that was wonderful to
see the fans in person after so long and
for the first time for i think a lot of
us um and now we've brought it to
gamescom and some of them are here and
you're seeing them again and recognizing
them and you get that real sense of what
it means to them to be a part of this
community and we've got all sorts going
on on the staff so i'll show off so
we've got
you can come and win things photos meet
the team so it's great being back but so
obviously it's been three years since
we've done anything like this what's
going on generally mike i'm gonna ask
you to start with sure see your thesis
anything happened in the last three
years what haven't we done
i think fellaini
and passion has always been to keep
building everything and over the last
three years and think back to the things
that we've added we've added the
emissary system but the players can go
and role players their trading companies
for extra rewards we've added new quest
types we brought in our seasonal
progression systems we brought in our
adventures we brought in our mysteries
we brought in like all these new ways to
play and one of the key ones of course
is their collaboration with disney on
pirates life
and you know since 2019.
thank you sir
just keep going yeah yeah and one of the
big ones was um what happened with the
pirates life so working with disney we
built all of that during the pandemic
you know being at home
working with this team we've worked
together for so long all of this
incredible bonds and relationships that
we built allowed us to get through what
was a very hard time the country is
stronger as a team and we're more
passionate than ever and obviously joe
you joined
steve thieves during the pandemic how
has it been like that dynamic of
actually coming into the studio it's the
best thing like you get a real sense
since day one of how closely the team
works together and how approachable
everyone is there's no one that you
can't just drop a message to but that
translates over to the studio where
we've got such a wonderful creative
nurturing environment but you can go and
knock on the door of anyone or bump into
them into the corridor and conversations
spark from that it's it's such a
wonderful thing to now have that
everyone's not just behind a screen
anymore and how do you feel joe i mean
again it's been a long three years we've
achieved a lot in that time as if you're
being back somewhere like this with what
we've done well well honestly like
i think we were talking about this kind
of earlier right like like you were
talking about during the pandemic the
team's all separated but being back in
the studio you just get that energy that
you feed off each other you feed off
kind of the team and the people around
you and coming to a show like this you
kind of get that same thing like i said
just you feed off the energy like and
even though we're exhausted and we've
always saw a person i've got a cough
street in my mouth at all times like
water on hand like but it is what i
promise um but uh it's just
it just gives you this energy and desire
and passion to just like want to go back
to the studio and just pour it into your
work and pour it into the game and you
kind of want to take it and bottle it
right and then take it back to the whole
studio like we always do when we go back
we do we take photos and videos and do a
big presentation and you really try and
just get people to understand what it's
like to meet the fans right and
you get the afterglow and this is what
we'll experience next week we'll have
this wonderful gamescom afterglow as we
get to take that back to the studio like
joe said and
put it into all the ambitious things
we've got planned for this year and
beyond well before we get on to that
jesus and the
you did like you mentioned it one of the
things we introduced in the last few
years was seasons
season seven yeah just gone live a
couple of weeks back indeed and it's a
biggie it is a big it's a biggie so
like what have you and i'm going to
start with you mike i will come to you
what have you kind of enjoyed seeing
people do and what has season seven like
introduced to cfp
well season seven you're right is a big
one and
the idea of being a pirate captain in
their world the idea that your ship
becomes
uh
it becomes an embodiment of who you are
in this world and your pirate journey
captaincy extends that pirate journey it
allows you to as a community often
requested to name your ship for the
first time to have this persistent
identity for your ship but beyond that
we're bringing in new progression
elements we're bringing in the captain's
log bringing ways that your session and
the ship now feels like a home so based
on how you play your ship represents who
you uniquely are as a pirate and how you
play in sea of thieves so i think one of
the most important things that has meant
a lot to us seeing the reception he's
just seen players go all in on that role
play you know we're going all in the
idea of this is who i am and when you
board someone's ship that representing
who they are in the sea of thieves and
why captaincy now what made sense to
bring it in at this point well
it's one of those features i think we
were always going to do it yeah um white
made sense now was and it kind of goes
back to the question around what's
happened in the last three years you
think about how much richer that cfd's
experience has become there's so many
ways to play in sea of thieves you know
there's so many ways to be who you
uniquely are as a pirate where the
sandboxes got richer there's new
activities there's new quests there's
new enemy threats there's just new ways
to play so captaincy coming in now and
rewarding you for all the unique things
that's now in the sandbox it kind of
just puts this lovely new layer to that
pirate journey and it just celebrates
this rich game that cfes has become and
i suppose joe from a community
perspective you must have seen this
played out in real time like how has the
community taken to captaincy
from day one they've been asking when
can we name our [ __ ] when can we do this
and then we've not only delivered that
we've delivered so much more on top of
it that people now have this pirate
identity that until now was just
conversations or role plays and we've
got people that are going for all those
fishing trinkets or people like myself
that it's it's all can inspired and
fought of the dams that you've completed
and you've got that real sense of
identity now from our players because
they can represent themselves on their
[ __ ] and they're they're color
coordinating everything and they're
decorating and they're
playing how they've always played but
now they're rewarded for it with their
own identity and they absolutely adore
it it's wonderful
beyond just the notion of being a pirate
we wanted the idea that pirate captains
in a world like heirs would become the
vips yeah they become the rock stars of
the world so as part of captaincy and
that's big update that we brought in
there's a set of perks and conveniences
that captains now have so when you own
your first ship in the sea of thieves
there's a unique cashing point just for
you in the cft's world to make
offloading that treasure it was part of
going out there and having adventures
making that feel so much more efficient
using the harpoon to harpoon the
treasure off the deck cashing that
treasure really efficiently but
alongside that as well you've got the
new trinket system so
this new progression system that they
unlock these trophies that represent who
you are there's the captain's voyages so
you can select exactly what you want to
do and store
all of the voyages that you could do on
this bookcase immersively in the
captain's cabin
as part of that as well you can go to
the ship right and you can purchase
resources right there from the outpost
and have them delivered to your barrels
so the idea that if you are a ship
captain in the sea of thieves you can
get your ship ready quickly you can pick
the adventure you're going to go on and
you can just walk straight on that ship
and have your adventures and then that
adventure be persistent there's that
sense of consequence for your actions
your ship showing the battle scars of
all your adventures you choosing to
maybe you want to keep that maybe you
want to role play with this kind of
battle scarred ship or you can pay a
small amount of gold to make the whole
pristine again so it really strengthens
and really amplifies everything that's
already unique about cs that second
option is me i have to pay to get it
redone i i get in too many fights
i love that though i love the way it
just allows players to be more uniquely
who they are yeah and like being out on
the waves and looking through the
spyglass and seeing all these ship names
and hero players chosen to represent
themselves i mean that that's the magic
and
it's enriched the sandboxes here these
and that's what we always want to do so
i'm gonna go now so we mentioned ship
names it's a biggie big part of
captaincy you don't have to tell me but
i'm going to ask a couple of you this
what did you name your ships i'm going
to start with you joe uh my name's my
sloop is little foot
my rare loadout rig is get red nice nice
galleon which is the one that we use the
most so if you see it on the seas come
and say hello and that's the purple
loadout and that is the purple rain with
the quartermaster sails there we go nice
nice how about you mike okay so i've got
a sloop and a break so for the sloop the
sloop is called the golden blade so fan
to see if these will know that
the silver blade the burning blade it's
a big part of their lore so the golden
blades a little tease for our fans maybe
someone that's really into the law but
nice loop is called the golden blade and
my break is called inferno
and that is actually a reference to
one-eyed willy's ship inferno in the 80s
classic the goonies and why mike is the
goonies because something that comes up
like
it's because the 80s was the best decade
like they all don't like that's nice
broadcast over yeah
we like you took the whole team to see
the goonies during development we did we
hired a cinema right now we had the
electric cinema out in birmingham very
lovely independent cinema um but yeah it
had some
pirate themed cocktails that they put on
and yeah we took the whole time to see
it because it was all about that
camaraderie that adventuring together
right in all seriousness like it's hard
not to get emotional when joe that's
such an incredible memory of the
development to see thieves and
in such a deep and meaningful way when
we went to watch the goonies together it
felt like we as a team were about to
embark on our own pirate adventure like
the characters in that movie and we knew
we wanted to create a game where the
bonds between the crew felt like the
bonds between the characters in the
goonies they're on this pirate adventure
they don't know what's going to happen
they're going to be surprised by all the
dangers and the peris that come their
way so
the goonies for us is just it's a lovely
memory but it's it really feels in tune
with the spirit of what sea of thieves
has always been yeah so joe instead of
asking you what your ship's called well
no one's asked me no one's asking you
mine was notorious brg which
works verbally doesn't work when written
so what's some of the favorite ships
you've seen though so what i love about
like the ship naming throughout the
community is obviously people trying to
make humorous things try and make stuff
that is going to get a reaction or get a
chuckle from from people when they look
through the kind of spy glass and see it
and stuff so like socks so sot final
boss like that that gave me a little
chuckle right that did like it's like
you see that it's like yeah i love that
people like role-playing as the fearsome
kind of
ai threat in the world but i just love
it i love that anything that makes me
chuckle is what gets me right there's so
much of that but that was that was one
that stuck in my head that i think
someone tweeted from god read it or
something but yeah and what about you
mike any favorites that is a great
example
hey we're awesome players have got this
new way to express their creativity and
to see if well the fact that we can
laugh about it together but honestly
there's so many examples but um usain
bolt
referencing usain bolt the olympic
medalist that made me chuckle um i like
the way that you felt like you had to
explain that
world known olympic medalist
but one one that i just can't forget
it's a little bit dark
but um
she kept the house
beautiful that's it really difficult
that is good
how about you joe
honestly
the really obvious ones are the ones
that make me giggle i ran across the
galleon that was just this boat is big
yeah and that was like yes
and it's those ones that i like but you
see them once you say you've got the
role-playing ones where they've gone for
some variation on something we've gone
and got in-game or you've got just the
funny puns that we've seen as well and
it's that creativity that you see and
you're like
you can almost judge what kind of pirate
they are yeah but not all the time and i
love that yeah you're right actually
because if someone's got a humorous like
this bonus big thing you can imagine
approaching them maybe like having a
life with them right and speak to them
over you know using the speaker jumping
or something yeah yeah so yeah yeah
you're right actually really adds a kind
of different sort of feeling doesn't it
to encounter other ships so i do
actually have the top ten boat names oh
okay
this is where we would have top of the
pops music okay for people of a certain
vintage
did you actually prep them tonight
i would say knowing them knowing their
fans yeah knowing gay community and the
role play of the world and generally how
things go down i would
i would predict
something like the black person you
would be quite my mind yeah and collect
your gift there's a lot of black there's
a lot of black pearls out there and
how awesome is that and that's that
original creativity and humor that we
love today for players yeah
come on let's
let people role play let people role
play what the game is all about and
you've gone joe it's like pearl's in
there yeah and there's got to be a
flying dutchman you would be quite right
three
no actually he's number seven
so are you uh usain bolt
correct there you go that's it so others
in the top 10. i'm not going to do an
exhaustive list but we have snoop dogg
snoop dogg that's very good yeah
why
why the letter y i don't want an
existential crisis while i'm sailing why
why why is this just like anybody just
actually yes let us know why
please oh and we hope it's not rude yeah
so we've also got unsinkable two yeah
okay oh there's got to be titanic in
there yeah jack's door that door yes
thousand sunny
oh yeah right okay
mary and queen
[Laughter]
then so it's live right now people are
playing as we speak so
can you mike probably best give us an
overview of where this fits within the
law and the story where are we yeah so
we're in a really interesting time in
the sea of thieves now in our
storytelling where
it's set against the backdrop of these
emerging factions in the sea of thieves
and
our players will know that last year as
part of the pirate's life the dark
brethren emerged
working with david jones and of course
davey jones got defeated because of the
valiant efforts of their players but the
dart brethren are still around with
amarantha their new member who's an
ex-sea dog and we've got everybody's
favorite duke so there's the dark
brethren there's of course the one and
only pirate lords and he's pirate
legends
players are often part of that and we've
got
the third area of that third faction
which is of course
uh captain flame heart of captain flame
heart and the reapers bones and the
servant of the flame so what you're
seeing now at this point in seattle's
history
is this factional war between these
pirate groups that have all got their
own vision for the pirates life and the
way they want the pirates life to be in
the sea of thieves and unfortunately
paul merrick has got himself ensnared in
the middle of that and in adventure six
players are recruited by the pirate lord
to go on this daring rescue mission into
the sea of the damned to the new hideout
of the dark brethren which is the
twisted sea dog tab and a memory of that
iconic sea dogs tavern from the main
world
and you work together with crews to save
merrick but
one of the big things that players will
play will always already realize is this
actually brings a chapter of merrick's
story that began with a hunger indeed
continue with the shrouded d to the
forsaken hunter where merrick was
unfortunately killed and went to the sea
of the damned to knowing hunter's cry he
brings this chapter of merrick's story
to a touching conclusion the story is
not over but it brings this part of the
story to a conclusion so definitely
worth experiencing that story because
it's going to have important
ramifications for the rest of it so i
met someone yesterday and they're a
massive fan of merrick and they wanted
to talk to you about that
they're literally they came to this day
down there
they had some questions deals can always
be struck yeah and i'm open to ideas but
it's merry christelling yeah that's what
it's going to come down
[Laughter]
so how far
are the adventures planned and like and
without teasing anything or giving it
away like how far out are we looking in
terms of where do you know the story is
how far out really far so i think
what's really cool
like thematically like where we want to
go and the direction we're heading into
and how we want to represent the
pirate's life in all these different
ways in the cities that is planned out
and multiple years worth
at a high level in terms of absolute
specifics of what the story beats are
and exactly which characters are
involved in what way that's planned out
it's probably a year a year and a half's
worth of storytelling and adventures
that we've got planned out and we need
to do that because that's the way that
you make things meaningful and make it
feel authentic to the sea of thieves
when we know that we know what's going
to happen with character in a year and a
year and a half's time we can start
seeding things early start bringing
players organically into that
storytelling we love to do that because
it makes everything feel more meaningful
and how do you think the community like
engage with the law like is it because
obviously it's not a pre-requisite to
playing the game but those who love law
love lore oh yes they do that i was
going to say you have to get those
specifics right because if one
thread is out of place if one
character isn't in the right they're
going to notice and they're going to tag
mike on twitter until he answers for his
law crimes
they know their stuff that's the thing
because they've been so invested since
day one and we've now stepped it up with
the amount of law we're delivering
and i know across our social channels
and on discord we've got separate
channels and we had to separate out the
launcher section because we've got
mysteries and adventures and then
general law and they're all over it and
they're sharing theories and they're
swapping stories and they thoroughly
embrace that side of the storytelling
that we've got now
and i love that i love it i mean that's
to me shows that a lot of their
community are invested in the world and
they care about our world and you're
right of course it's not a prerequisite
to play sea of thieves sea of thieves is
this wonderful sandbox adventure game
where you get to choose your own
adventures but we've always believed
that the more meaning and purpose we can
put into the world the deeper we can
make that world feel the easy is to
immerse yourself in those adventures and
that role play so it's there waiting
full of surprises for players that want
it but it's not a prerequisite for
seafood and how do we bring you like
expanded universe into this
like you know again with the planning
we need to know what's coming but like
you know say the the most recent novel
we planned that was it two years ago we
had the first pregnancy quite a long
time ago wasn't it yeah so how it's like
how do you kind of keep all of this is
there a
is there a big board with lots of
we do have we do have a law bible
um which is which is quite high level if
it was too detailed it would get
hundreds and hundred thousands of pages
probably um but it's a lot of meetings
it's a lot of discussion it's a lot of
building up that knowledge together as a
team around i mean you're right
everything in the eu is canon to our
story so what players have seen before
with the tells the cfp's law book the
two novels that we've never got out the
rpgs and the expansion all of those
stories are canon to our world and
there's a huge responsibility that comes
with that
experiencing any of those materials
should be just another window into the
cft's world and when you play the game
it should strengthen and vice versa both
of those elements so we have to get it
right every time
that's the pressure yeah
so we had our first decision point
adventure
where the community effectively decided
wrongly
calm down can we edit this out
yeah so the community were able to
decide the fates of the world so we're
gonna start asking what side were you
along so
i i was ruined golden sands
and you even have yeah
how about yourself don't remind me joe
i'd actually forgotten that you were on
that side
save golden sands you're surrounded all
the way i am so i mean i'm ensnared
the reasons
no i think
as i mean as we've seen today
interacting with people here at gamescom
merrick is such a beloved character and
what merrick stands for and you know
he's a salty pirate that's lived his
life in the cities and people love that
character and i think for me
it's such it's a more interesting story
and i'm it's unbelievable that the
community chose to go that way the fact
that they bonded together
to take this positive action to defend
gold and stuff so which side were you
joe i think we can guess we're in golden
sands like absolutely and obviously all
on the side of sea of thieves sorry i
was going to make it i'm not going to
move away from that i was going to make
a sunax trust no that'll say that but we
won't do that because that would be the
most effective thing you could ever do
moving on quickly did we have the result
you expected like genuinely no it was
well i don't i can predict no
i kept i kept watching the conversations
happening and we we'd made all these fun
things across our discord servers so
that people showed their allegiance
rather than anything else
and the reaper's hideout was just
burning stuff lyrics was coordinating
and i had no way of knowing which way it
was gonna go and as much as i wanted to
ruin it i'm not gonna lie i spawned in
my first play session afterwards on
golden sands and was really happy i was
like look at it i think as a designer
you think you think so much about the
psychology of players and how they'll
react to certain things and
i genuinely believe personally that it
would go the way it would go to that
negative choice it would go to the
reaper they choose chaos who wouldn't
want to see what happened if the reapers
won because golden sands it's about
taking it back to that neutral state
which which it will evolve now because
the choice has been made but i always
thought people would side with the
reapers so
just blown away by the fact that didn't
happen i thought that was a lovely
surprise and it's going to be really
interesting because players see
throughout this year
what's going to happen to golden sands
now and how that's going to play out
yeah
and honestly and i love the well knowing
kind of what the next decision point is
and where the kind of where we're
leading to like that is going to be
another huge moment for our community to
have to again make a choice right and
the impact that's coming with that right
without teasing too much but it's like
you know later this year there's going
to be another big one like i think
bigger in terms of kind of emotional i
think yeah the emotional investment in
the next one i think will be bigger well
so i'm going to ask again you've kind of
pre-empted the question but all right
so with we're having another decision
point that's happening yeah okay there
we go
and it's a big one but so there's been a
question like if we were to like scale
it based on the last one is this bigger
similar what can people expect
bigger
it's absolutely bigger it cuts right to
the core of
some of the key characters in the sea of
thieves and we wanted to do that we
wanted to drive a big world change with
gold and sands obviously we set that
over the first adventure trade island um
and picking golden sands because it was
a beloved outpost beautiful palm trees
it's paradise we knew that would trigger
an emotional response for our players
but
we've done that now we've seen how
players interact with it we've learned
some lessons about how to set up these
type of live storytelling events and now
we're going to go even further we're
going to be even more ambitious with
these second choices yeah so look out
for that and also mechanically again
without spoiling it but you've learned a
lot from how we designed the first one
and the activities people were doing and
how we're going to be kind of like i
love what we've got planned there in
terms of like the yeah just the
activities people going to be doing and
how that's going to play out and how
it's just going to make the whole sea of
thieves feel so different during that
time period yeah yeah it'll be it'll be
a real moment in time and joe's right
we've deliberately in adventures so far
done very different things
one's more focused on the pure gameplay
one's more focused on the storytelling
all these different set pieces because
we're we're learning and we're going to
take those learnings into the future
adventures that we've planned out we're
already doing that and you've touched on
it slightly there but how how is it
planned like in terms of production
as an executive producer
[Laughter]
like how do you kind of prepare for that
decision point though like you know do
we have both tracks ready to go or is it
more of a case of well we assume this
will happen or we have a more neutral
state
that genuinely is probably one of the
most complex things we've ever done well
you've got like two of these
um but you've got to plan for both
outcomes we deliberately don't start
building the bigger things yeah because
that would be an incredible waste of the
team's time with more valuable things
but we have to plan out a junction point
so earlier on when i was talking about
the fact that we've got adventures
planned out for the next year and a half
there's almost a fork in the roads there
where there's almost optional in this
option b based on some of these
community choices that we're planning so
it makes a complex job even more complex
but
like
so worthwhile yeah so worthwhile to see
that play out with the community um and
joe just kind of we're gonna wrap up in
a moment but like from what you know of
the next decision point like do you
think we're gonna see that kind of
ground swell from the community i guess
like they're gonna i think they're gonna
go wild for the next one i think it's
really exciting and with that other
decision point they've seen how they can
alter the world that they're playing in
and that most of them spend a lot of
their time in and i think this next one
really is gonna step it up and i think
we will see that
resurgence of the passion that we saw in
the last decision point and then some
so to wrap up then we're here for a
couple more days what can people expect
like from us at gamescom
just come to the stand basically like
there's always going to be a thieves
crew at the stand right and each day we
have
there's a meet and greet slot that we've
tweeted out i don't know whether but
it's five o'clock today five p.m
today and then one o'clock i think every
other day i think but um
uh and then yeah you could come play you
can win the medallions like you can
watch the stream but but the whole point
we're here is just to chat and meet with
fans right that's why we've brought so
many people here that's the energy we
want come and come and give my feedback
and questions
honestly that is that is the privilege
of being at a live show like this
nothing energizes you more than talking
to fans feeling their passion hearing
their questions and their feedback we
don't just want to hear the good stuff
we want to hear the bad stuff we want to
learn we want to make this service of
sea of thieves in this pirate world the
best it can possibly be if you love
pirates sea of thieves should be the
game for you so we love nothing more
than talking to other fans we love the
game as much as their fans do what a
wonderful place to leave it
don't even ask any questions about
scotland what's that now what about
school
so thank you but this has been great so
thank you ever so much and as joe says
if you are here do you come down and see
us please do please don't honestly but
if not um we'll see you on the seas
thank you bye
[Applause]
[Music]
has fallen humanity is hanging on by a
threat but you know what it's not all
bad news because our planet is full of
fat ass dinosaurs and seriously who
doesn't love a dinosaur seriously
in this exciting new glimpse at second
extinctions full release players get to
explore more of earth than ever before
the full launch adds a new vast open map
for players to roam more dinosaurs to
fight a revamp progression system and
tons of exciting new features i mean i'm
talking about co-op first person shooter
and mutated dinosaurs i am so in
here's a brand new trailer for second
extinction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
i hope this reaches you
this city is falling apart
chaos
madness
death and there might be no going back
[Music]
but you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lies
[Music]
too much of you
but i don't have a choice
only you can do this
please
help me
finally
we meet
son
[Music]
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right i'm here for you don't worry
[Music]
if
protect
fulfill
your destiny
hello charlie here with two of the
brilliant untwisted minds from neowiz
who created a game that's reimagined
pinocchio as a
a ruthless killing machine to cleanse a
plague infested world made by the studio
behind beloved fantasy mmo bless
unleashed and coming from a team of
developers who worked on the absolutely
awesome monster hunter world i am super
excited about this one please welcome
juwon choi and jason park
it's lovely to meet you whoever's
underneath there um
this is haunting
truly haunting
should we have a look and see if we can
find the humans underneath yeah let's go
let's do it yeah i'm gonna do the slow
reveal
here they are
jason and juwon
[Laughter]
we have a joker
hello nice to meet you there they are
amazing they've joined us welcome now
when i think of pinocchio it doesn't
quite look uh up to the trailer that we
saw just now so could you let us know
where the idea of pinocchio is killing
machine actually came from
our team is called off and this is the
first time we've developed a single
player console game
so we need a way to get our name out
there
in order to stick in the minds of the
people
our strategies was to choose our subject
that was very well known but transform
it into something completely original
um we eventually choose the adventures
of the pinocchio but there wasn't a key
decision
we first thought about what features we
wanted our source like game to have and
the first don't ever reference the jack
of fantasy or medieval things the second
the story shouldn't be chinese and we
should be able to enjoy it edit or dutch
and last
the game should be full of adventures
and unforgettable characters
this is natural related to pinocchio
because it matches the conditions we
sell
i had a lot of pinocchio when i was
child but i was shocked when i lead
again more carefully recently the
adventures of the piano kill is
definitely not story for children but
rather like an r-rated movie for adults
it was a real pleasure to take the
fantastic source material and create our
own original story tell really i bet it
is and now we're at gamescom showing it
off to the world yeah
so when you prompted the initial idea of
making a game based on the story of
pinocchio
honestly i was not convinced at all yeah
i was thinking that the
pinocchio is a story for just for kids
that sure pro or 90 or so like games
however even though i read the pinocchio
story long time ago
i i live in my [ __ ] so i went to
bookstore bought a book and read it
again
and what i've learned is that
pinocchio is not just a character it's
more like a reflection of human nature
and filled with a lot of your unique and
attractive characters
that's when i realized
we need some
this is something we have to do
revitalizing this amazing story as a
game i think it sounds like i might need
a reread of pinocchio then um but until
then do you want to give us a bit of a
deep dive of the story in the world that
your pinocchio inhabits
as you already know elijah p is based on
the original story of pinocchio
which is actually quite brutal
and while the main characters in elijah
p are for the pinocchio our game's story
is completely different and filled with
new events for example
larger pe takes place in the imaginary
city of crotch on where petrification
disease is spreading and causing a lot
of conflict
and while you meet a lot of familiar
characters from the pinocchio
they want to be anything anything like
you remember
we introduced the black lobby
brotherhood before
but i'd also like to tell you about
antonia who appears at the beginning of
the trailer
and the original story antonia is
actually antonio yeah japanese friend
that is all i can live today though
i will save the rest for the future i
was going to say i definitely do
remember these masks from my childhood
it's got to be said
yeah so me too
my favorite is black laby brotherhood
they're also in the original story
and you know poor black rabbit holding a
coughing on their shoulders
they're uh in lizard feet they're not
just arriving they're neutral warriors
they're still carrying a coffin and
always trying to skid you into it
i really want to see how you guys
survive when they're hunting
so
in order to go up against them i have
seen from the trailer so far that there
are some ridiculous weapons and you can
even take some enemies to the wood shop
with them if i saw that correctly um so
talk us through the combat we can expect
from liza p and how similar is it to the
souls like games we've been seeing
recently
um i can confidently say the elijah p is
full of unique and one-of-a-kind system
and the first system i'd like to talk
about is the weapon combination shift
style weapons are divided into two parts
the blade and the handle and can be
combined in countless ways each blade
and the handle have their own weight
motions pictures and special skills
called forever arch
okay so players are free to mix and
match and create the perfect weapon for
them it should be fun to try out
outdoor the hundreds of possible
combinations wow
and another unique system in light of p
is the legion arm system
which probably already shown on the main
characters of left arm yep yep he has
actually valuable perfect yeah so it's
possible to modify it with the parts and
the usual special skills
they are particularly flat and dynamics
and can also be strengthened
i've been found to choose the right or
legal amount for the situation you are
here now i had a chance to play it
earlier by the way i'm just gonna say
and it is so so difficult so i just let
anyone know out there that this game is
so difficult you are going to absolutely
love it but to answer the elephant in
the room obviously the original
pinocchio game had a big emphasis on his
nose growing with every single lie so i
have to ask does this element of the
pinocchio story play into lies of p at
all
yeah
first of all i think that
lying is the most important aspect of
the original story
and when you really think about it
humans are capable of lying and there
can also be food for their humanity
this also means that we approach the
concept of life in a completely
different way than the original
think about it is there any more than a
more human than using lies to achieve
something yeah we think that in order to
become real human one has to lie and
that is reflected in the game by players
experiencing a variety
the choices they make will also affect
amber yeah as for what this might do to
his nose
um i can support it for you
you need to find it up for yourself but
i can guarantee you're not expecting
anything
i tell you what when the full game comes
out then the first thing i'm testing is
the lying
yeah
in the game you can lie if you you'll be
a human but always remember like levi
brothers is always looking for a chance
for all liars entered coffins
right okay moving swiftly onwards from
that then um there had to be a ton of
people putting a lot of time into lysap
to uh pull the strings pun intended to
get a game like this off the ground so
can you talk about the development
process and were there any difficulties
actually getting people to buy into this
reimagining
actually in korea the majority of games
are online kids and mobile games
so there aren't many developers with
expertise in single players games for
consoles okay
so we did a lot of trial and error and
made a lot of mistakes but this was
unavoidable despite
these challenging circumstances the fact
that our team not
had a lot of developers who already had
the experience with the console game
project was a major help yeah most of
all our team absolutely loves console
games so it was easy to get everyone on
board with our opinions for elijah p
yeah i would like to give all the credit
to our team members and
they are the reason why elijah p could
come this far yeah and i'm really really
proud of our team and i'm sure they are
so proud of you both sat here today
representing the game as well so shout
out to youtube yeah
yeah it is the first time for us to make
a single player game we all have a lot
of experiences on developing
action games but only limited to all 9
games
at first i was thinking that
making single player games would be
easier
in terms of technical perspective like
no networking
issues etc
but it didn't take long that i realized
i underestimated
yeah our game needed a lot of pictures
we haven't
even imagined when you develop online
games
you only have one playable character
which is which is easier to make because
online games normally have more than
five
very true but this one player character
i mean pinocchio
requires i guess you know
10 times more animation than the online
game makes sense yeah yeah pinocchio use
a lot of different types of weapons and
each weapon requires
total unique unique animation of
their color setup
that's a
total unique set of animation
so i had i have to admit i
our initial plan was
offered in terms of estimating the
the cost of the animations yeah
so if you look at our studio
and probably you can see our animated
artists and combat designers yelling
each other
and arguing all the time we are still in
this chaos but anyway we are enjoying it
and
definitely we'll be better at planning
at that time well i really appreciate
that you brought the chaos to us here in
germany but before we run out of time i
do want to give you to the floor to
share anything you want with everyone
out there about liza pease before its
release
actually we didn't expect a large appeal
to get this much interest and love from
gamers
we really really want to thank you all
for the tremendous level of support
we'll do our absolute best and are sure
that you'll be mesmerized by the city of
city of cards
and take care and
see you in the
xbox game pass next to you oh yeah
[Music]
yeah for everybody at gamescom don't
forget to visit our booth and play the
demo enjoy
and please share your experiences with
us
thank you for having us today and enjoy
gamescom with rise of p
guys thanks again so much for joining me
but now dancing robots creepy crashless
dummies and theme park rides you really
don't want to visit are just some of the
trippy treats crammed into this
wonderfully weird next trailer set in an
ultimate or alternate 1955 where robotic
technology has grown nail-bitingly
powerful it's up to one rogue agent to
take a stand for humanity and if he
doesn't well let's just say that's not
good for anybody this is a brand new
look at atomic heart
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hey welcome back everyone i'm here with
steven takowski from 505 games to talk
about all the gunfire reborn wildness we
just saw in that trailer before its
console cloud and pc release on game
pass on october 27th stephen thank you
for joining us thank you for having me i
really appreciate the opportunity listen
no problem at all we appreciate it and
welcome to gamescom
thank you i mean i'm having a great time
good to be back right absolutely good
okay so gunfire reborn's been around for
a little while now right it's coming to
xbox console and cloud for the very
first time just great news so give us an
introduction to the game sure so gunfire
reborn is a level based uh adventure
game with fps
roguelike and
rpg elements and you pretty much play
with several characters who will have
various abilities
and you will
go on adventures through four different
uh environments and in those
environments there's unique levels
enemies and bosses great and you can see
from the footage there it's super bright
super colorful super fast now it's a
roguelite as well right so
i'm right in thinking that every time
you start a new run it's going to be a
different experience yeah so yeah it's a
true roguelike
each route is going to be different each
time you play so it'll always be
different from one game play to the next
you don't know what drops you're getting
so you have to adjust to your
environment because you really don't
know what you're going to have and
but you know along the way you're going
to find different weapons you're going
to find weapon inscriptions which are
you know different rarities of weapons
and uh you don't know what to expect but
you know you just got to be prepared and
you know you'll know there's going to be
a boss at the end of each level right
which is your typical roguelike
experience but uh yeah that's pretty
much it excellent and you saw from the
trailer as well you can play solo and
you can play co-op multiplayer which is
awesome but let's talk about solo first
right what is that roguelite gunfire
reborn experience if you're just playing
on your own well the solo experience is
great you know a lot of games you want
to play roguelike with like friends this
one plays solo it's the best way to
level up your character unlock new
characters and upgrade your character so
soul experience is more like an rpg
and uh you know there's four
environments that you have to go through
it can be challenging because you only
get one revive for the entire experience
right and so in solo play you're
essentially yeah as you said you're
leveling up you're unlocking new
characters you're working on your
profile basically to then take it into
multiplayer is that right that's correct
and you know multiplayer is
super fun with gunfire reborn uh you can
play four player co-op and it's just a
great experience it's such you know
clean combat um it's really exciting to
see it on you know xbox game pass
because you go you play with your
friends on xbox and
it's just really smooth combat and uh
you know you really learn to play with
your friends you have to have unique
strategies with your friends and you
know everyone picks a hero based on uh
how you want to go into it but you don't
know what you're going to get you know
what weapons you're gonna have and so
you do have to adjust on the fly even
with a group of friends excellent i love
that let's talk about those heroes then
i think we got a sense of them from the
trailer right we've got a really
colorful cast of of animal heroes yeah
talk us through them and pick out your
favorite for us as well sure so we have
a cat we have a dog
you know we have a bird we have a snow
leopard
we have a rabbit we have a turtle they
all have their unique abilities and
perks um you know some of them are
optimal for like elemental damage some
of them are great for delivering you
know melee damage or crits so you know
you do have to spend some time i mean
the game has a lot there so if you want
to spend the time and drill down and
learn the game you will be rewarded it's
an excellent game that you can really
spend like hundreds of hours on and we
have a massive community online who
really appreciate it you see guides
everywhere on real optimal builds you'll
see tier lists for everything and it's
just a really popular game and you have
to decide which hero is best for you um
you know for me you know i would say
getting started the crown prince is a
very well balanced character definitely
recommended uh you know any weapon he
can use and uh you know he does
corrosive damage with his bomb uh which
is really important and then you know
you have uh you know each character
has an optimal strategy you just got to
decide which one's best for you nice
okay you mentioned the community i want
to come back to that because there is
this incredible community already built
around gunfire reborn so you know i want
to give them a shout out and come back
to them but speaking of animals you know
yeah you've got the animal heroes i
think i also saw an animal being used as
a weapon right like a lizard as a weapon
yeah that's called justice and you know
very creative weapons you know
there's a whole arsenal there's eight
different classes of weapons to choose
from you know you could be short-ranged
you've got your shotgun long-range
sniper um you know you have to decide
what do you want to do pistol do you
want to use melee and based on your
strategy based on your class you know
your hero you can decide and but it's
roguelike so each game you don't know
what you're getting but you have choices
you know there's generally three choices
unless you know a boss drops you know an
item for you then you have to pick up
that weapon or you can choose not to
pick up that weapon and you could also
refund the weapons as well so you know
you have a lot of options for your game
play and
that you look at the stats on each of
these weapons and
it you have to do your research and
you'll be rewarded for a game like this
i love it all right so we've talked
about the heroes a bit about the weapons
i need to know about these villains as
well who are we up against in gunfire
reborn sure so uh in and you know
enemies in gunfire there's three classes
you know you have your standard enemies
um you know you defeat them you get soul
essence you get copper uh you have your
elite enemies that you find in like
balds which are these like hidden cracks
throughout the levels that you can get
some pretty sweet rewards from uh
whether it's like a weapon or a goblet
or a scroll and then you have the bosses
at the end of the levels and usually
you'll get like a legendary scroll two
weapons you know goblet uh soul essence
and copper and uh you know those bosses
definitely can be challenging at first
but once you play the game and get used
to it um you realize they all have a
strategy to defeat um you know some
people we've seen they jump into it they
can be a little bit challenging but you
know after you really do a little bit of
research they become much easier and
it's just all fun yeah i that's one of
the things i've experienced playing you
know in my early runs i was really
getting rinsed by the bosses but you
know as you go through and through
roguelike style level up you get it you
work out you know but some of the bosses
are huge right i mean i caught sight a
couple in the trailer there oh yeah
they're huge but you know as you win and
you gather soul essence and you level up
your character right it just gets easier
from there yeah and especially when
you're playing with your friends and
co-op as well and you can bring all that
fire
all right yeah we talked about the
community you mentioned them earlier
huge community already in place for
gunfire reborn community keeps coming
back for more um how are you working
with that community and that fan base to
develop the game and you know what can
we expect in the future for gunfire sure
so we're always listening to the
community you know people write guides
and make videos and the game is
constantly getting balanced in order to
deliver an amazing experience like i
said there's millions of players already
in the community who are really enjoying
it and you know we pay attention to them
you know we do have a lot of content
that's coming we'll be announcing soon
um but you know we take in community
feedback in order to create an optimal
experience because we want them to keep
playing i love it love it so i guess the
gunfire reborn community is going to be
a great place for xbox players
to start when they start playing but
given that you know this whole new xbox
community is coming to the game both on
console and cloud and pc through game
pass
you know what do you um
how would you sort of say to them why
should they jump into game fiery sure so
it definitely has amazing replayability
it's very accessible you know if you're
a roguelike fan or you're brand new to
roguelites it's great experience very
very clean combat
it doesn't take too long to pick up it
takes a while to master but you can just
jump into it have a great experience if
you have three friends standing by ready
to play it's the perfect co-op game to
have a great time and you'll spend
endless hours with your friend and you
get to you know have animal creatures
that you're you're taking control of and
it's it's just a cool experience so uh
yeah great stephen thank you so much i'm
so excited to play and it feels like one
of those games you can get together with
your friends of all ages and just have a
total blast well thank you so much for
having me steven it's been a pleasure
really appreciate it um okay so there's
nothing quite like gamescom
and it turns out you've all missed this
incredibly special event just as much as
i have so here's a glimpse of what this
brilliant show means to the xbox family
all over the world
[Music]
what i love about gamescom is the fact
that this is bigger than even this is an
opportunity for all of us from the whole
world to meet each other to play
together to have fun
this is a chance to meet the people who
shares with your passion for the gaming
also you can buy stuff that will remind
you one day yeah this year i've been on
gamescom
so looking forward to be there again and
i'm so excited to have a chance to meet
you all
see you
for me gamescom is not only the expo but
most of all it's huge gaming
celebrations opportunity to meet the
people meet the gamers meet the fans
from around the world is really special
and i think that everyone who has
opportunities should go to the cologne
at least once
for gamescom i'm most looking forward to
meeting some new friends as well as
being reunited with some old xbox family
that i haven't seen in so long in person
so i can't wait to see and hang out with
everybody all in the name of games it's
gonna be fun
what memory of gamescom that i will
never forget is the 2018 fan fest boat
party that they threw it's a really cool
place to meet other xbox fans but also
it was the first time i ever met graham
and i'll never forget it because he and
i clearly have great fashion taste
because we were wearing the exact same
shoes to the party
bonjour from friends what i like the
most about gamescom is discovering the
work of the talented teams working on
the tomorrow's games discovering new
ones new stories and especially talking
with fan about our favorite games enjoy
the gamescom 2022
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i am joined by mikey and maddie from
scratch games who are here to give us an
exclusive look at high on live thank you
so much both for joining us
thank you for having us great to be here
and i'm sure the fans are going to be
super excited about this segment because
you have a tons of gameplay to show us
and i want to see it definitely but
before we jump into that could you give
us like a quick overview of what high on
live means
yeah so high on life is the new game
from justin royland studios watch games
it takes place it starts out on earth
you're kind of an aimless teenager you
don't really know where you're going
with your life aliens show up they
discover that humans are the best drugs
in the universe and you pair up with a
talking gun that you find to sort of
stop them from ending your species
basically
so yeah we're going to be seeing a bit
of content from the intro tutorial level
to start um you know some fast forward
sort through here but it's just because
we can only fit so much in this segment
so is that like the typical game from
scratch games you would have
yeah so we kind of we kind of have weird
games like if you know we kind of found
each other we like making weird stuff we
all love comedy we all love weird sci-fi
so
it really is right in our wheelhouse
it's just a leveled up version of things
we've done in the past
amazing so i would say let's just jump
right into the gameplay right because
what people want to see
sounds
great nice house you got
real ritzy way better than my bench oh
wow you really made yourself at home huh
oh there you are who's this weirdo and
why is he setting up a
huge alien computer in our living room
okay
first of all that alien computer is a
very expensive and surprisingly
operational bounty 5000 so uh you're
welcome
i've got just the thing a small time
local gangster by the name of nine torg
she took my favorite knife she's got an
operation out in the slums
maybe a killer and get my knife back
then we'll talk maybe take you out to
glumpies to celebrate all right so we we
just head out to the slums no [ __ ] you
gotta use the bounty 5000 to initiate a
bounty that's what i went through all
the trouble of setting it up for
my knife we're looking for the gateway
to the slums i guess looking it
shouldn't be too far listen just follow
the way so i just
um it's a little forward like is that
the usual demo is that a cockroach
uh yeah are you talking about fast
forward yeah
so we we're actually showing the full
demo here to pass behind closed doors
but for the purposes of this video we're
just sort of fast forwarding to make
time i understand and the family was at
my house where do i live in there is
that my family yeah yeah so uh early on
in the game kenny gives you the ability
to teleport your entire house to escape
from the cartel so when you teleport
your house your sister's in the house so
you kind of bring her with you
and she's not too happy about that at
first
and the other guy you see in there
that's gene he's a legendary bounty
hunter at least he was legendary bounty
hunter kind of fell on hard times and
he's homeless and he sees this
opportunity as a way to sort of get your
house so he's like i'll train you if you
let me crash on your couch if you die i
get to keep the house basically and so
he's really in the beginning he's really
hoping you die i understood
yeah the house is sort of your main hub
and then you have the rest of bloom city
for sci content nbc's lots of good stuff
[Music]
well well
look what we got here fresh meat hey
there fresh meat welcome to the slums
fresh meat
oh boy here we go
kid what's wrong fresh meat you scared
of a little kid yeah i have a little kid
look at me
i'm sorry this kid is this is annoying
what's this all about well honestly he's
just supposed to be annoying basically
so we implemented this
patented squanch shove tech basically
where characters get in your face and
push you around it's such a funny little
mechanic and he's one of the first
characters you encounter that's doing
this to you and he's really pressuring
you to shoot him but you don't have to
you can skip it yeah
yeah you meet uh his mom later and he's
actually 30s okay okay so not really
technically you're not killing kids and
it's your choice
[Music]
hey you can't pass through here it's
nine towards term jesus enough with
everyone getting in our way we just want
to kill nine torg yeah right you kill
nine torque get lost
so this is exciting we're in our first
combat um yeah who are we fighting in
this kenny's primary ability yeah so
this is the first time you're really
getting to use kenny and these aren't
the main enemies you're fighting these
are sort of a lower level set of goons
and they actually think they're the
strongest enemies in the game but they
find out by the end of this mission that
they're really not and they're just the
ones in the first level it's really
funny it's a really funny sequence
and for kenny you're seeing basically
his primary fire right now this is early
in the game so you're learning how to
use them but throughout the game he'll
get alternate abilities each gun kind of
has three modes one of them is always
going to affect traversal and then on
top of that there's mods for each gun
oh hey you want to see a cool party
trick i used to do amy at those spinny
platforms come on come on give it a shot
it'll be fun
yeah i told you did you see how fun that
was i call it my glob shot it comes out
of my trick hole okay
i'm afraid to ask this question what is
a trickle is that just american i'm
sorry i thought that was worldwide
but apparently not
so all the guns in the game have three
separate abilities so primary secondary
as we mentioned and then there's an
ability fire what you're seeing here can
be used in combat but it can also be
used to open up new traversal areas and
each gun in the game will sort of open
up new areas you can go back to areas
that you were before and kind of explore
find um you know content collectibles
and also get new npc interactions
yeah we're really trying to push that
light metroidvania feel so the levels
are really dense
you i'm sick of this i want to tear
through someone's guts oh i think
they're talking about gene tonight
got it freak we've had enough of your
[ __ ] yeah it's your fault stevie lax
is dead i was in love with him did you
know that i loved him and now his hands
cut coming just the way it should be
[ __ ] him hey guess what i have another
secret trick you can use the power of
negotiation let's try reasoning with
these guys knock on the door tell me how
you play
you insufferable
when i'm loose oh
who's there who are you uh hey hello
there friends oh i i think it's the
buyer hey are you the buyer
no i'm just here to do my laundry it's
even clean i just i'm a laundry head
can't stop washing stuff over here this
room's off limits everything you need is
in the front get out of here good luck
with your laundry
i mean i have a ton of laundry at home
especially after gamescom but i've
noticed there's a lot of dialogue in
this thing can you tell us a little bit
about that yeah so we actually started
out kind of writing out a big dialogue
tree our head writer alec rob was an
amazing writer and kind of makes twine
games in his spare time so we had it
down
and then once people got in the booth we
kind of encouraged a little bit of
improv to keep things fresh and funny uh
and then all of that amounts to
basically a huge selection of dialogue
choices and so you just heard him
talking about his ex-lover stephanie
lacks
if you knock on the door before that you
don't even have a chance to give that
answer because you don't know that
information so there's a lot of stuff
like that throughout the game that that
you're kind of opting into without even
knowing
nice job they told us this fire was a
real prankster oh you come on that was
pretty [ __ ] up that joke is gonna [ __ ]
me up
you got him good okay though but enough
of that uh let's show them the product
all right here's the product a genuine
talking knife i gotta be honest with you
he's a real piece of he's extremely
violent he basically only talks about
wanting to kill people in very
disturbing ways [ __ ] you i'm gonna carve
out your cavity gonna make it three
times as big you're it's just gonna drop
right out of there let's see what i'm
talking about oh a perfect that's
exactly what we're looking for yeah yeah
great go ahead feel free to inspect it
try it out see how he feels in your hand
yeah yeah free me let's go let's go
psycho on these
actually you want to just swing out the
air a bit like far away from us yeah
thanks
come on what are you
oh [ __ ] yes thank you pleased to meet
you i'm knifey now use me use me let me
stop these [ __ ] heads oh just a
reminder uh don't do anything crazy when
you're holding the knife just like look
at it see if you like it put it back
yeah thank you
oh [ __ ] yeah
yes more more i need more stabbing
definitely nine torque but let's put a
pin in the whole gene thing how do we
get out of here with my tether ability
i'm more than just a knife you racist i
can tether too look up and latch on
i'm sorry but these lines guys but i
remember i remember nike from the first
trailer and i think for fans he has been
fan favorite from the debut tell me
everything about him yeah so he's by far
my favorite weapon in the game he's
voiced by michael cusack who's awesome
he's so funny
and throughout the game basically he
functions as a knife but he's there to
kind of always pick on you and say funny
stuff he also has this tether ability
which affects traversal through the
levels so once you get them you can kind
of go back and some of the levels were
horizontal now they're more vertical and
there's things you can get that you
couldn't get before yeah it's pretty
cool the night the levels really open up
once you get knifey and there's a bunch
of other traversal abilities you can use
in tandem with him and you also uh can't
open chests until you get knifey which
you'll see right here these are our lug
boxes uh hopefully we'll be selling
plushies of these plushies and knifey um
you know i was gonna have that side
hustle
um
so you're actually also getting pretty
close to the end of the level here uh
you're gonna fight the uh the boss nine
tour because your first bounty uh you're
gonna be able to use all of your
abilities that you've learned in the
level together so your primary your
secondary you're gonna be tethering
around the air arena and you're also
gonna be deflecting with knife so you
put it all together you fight nine
torque
[Music]
come on a minute we're hurting you
[Applause]
here you can still use me if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
i'm not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect
attacks i'll slice them up
i'll cut their heads off
and i'll rip their limbs off do
everything long enough and cut right
into them i'll cut them
off and eat it you know this slug
matches your toxic personality
[Music]
incoming laser
laser just for you
i'm taking you with me
stay alive i think she's basically done
for
yeah
so actually we're showing this full
playthrough of what is essentially the
first bounty you get so we're showing
that behind closed doors to press
there should be full videos online of
the whole playthrough people to check
out and we're just so excited to finally
get into people's hands and see their
reactions it's been a real labor of love
for us on the team amazing well i can
say this is a gloomy globby blast right
but when can people get their hands on
the game so december 13th is gonna come
out we're really excited for everybody
to check it out we're working really
hard on it yeah seriously please check
it out like this is really really a
special game to us and we really hope
you guys like it well mikey maddie i
have to say first of all thank you so
much for us
sleeping letting us sleep in your game i
really appreciate it
and yeah thanks for having us at the
show and enjoy the rest of gamescom
thank you thank you so much for having
us
and now we are going to take a look at a
game set in the warhammer 40k universe
so just a little change of pace here i
don't know about you but nothing signals
the end of summer like a good co-op
shooter and just as the darkness starts
creeping in we have the perfect slice of
shootie socializing for you set in the
city of teresa play as one of four types
of recently released prisoners as a last
resort to protect the city it's time for
the rejects to rise this is dark tide
dark tide is a first person co-op game
set in the grim dark future of warhammer
40 000.
welcome to tertia a sprawling hive city
on the brink of destruction
you
are a reject
a convict free to serve the inquisition
in this darkest of hours
[Music]
it is your duty to fight
and
if necessary
die
for the emperor
you can expect no help
no reinforcements
you
are persian's last line of defense
rejects will rise
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
emma hola muy
[Music]
yellow
[Music]
[Music]
unlikely
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
oh that was nice wasn't it nice little
moment of tranquility there in a minute
all the fun of gamescom how's it going
folks welcome back i am excited to
welcome aaron harneus the creative
director and lead game designer at
wishfully to talk about the absolutely
gorgeous planet of lana adam thank you
so much for being here i cannot wait to
talk about how beautiful this game looks
but first of all right give us an intro
to planet elana we just saw the trailer
but what should we expect yeah so planet
of lana is a side-scrolling sci-fi
puzzle adventure right and you play this
young girl called lana and and at your
side you have to have this little cute
creature companion yeah and together you
go out on this epic adventure you know
through the world of this
this planet that's set far away in a
galaxy and you you're going on a rescue
mission to try and save lana's big
sister that's been taken away by an
invading robot army
yeah that's the gist of it so super
exciting for everyone attending gamescom
here this year and for you as well
personally i'm sure is that you can
actually play planet of lana for the
first time here right yeah so excited
about that you can play planet of lana
here in the xbox booth as well as in the
thunderphone booth here in hall 8. so
very excited about that and this is
actually the first time we're showing
the game at 2 media and so very excited
about that so what's in the demo like
what can we expect from yeah so the demo
is quite an early part of the game right
so it's actually the first part where
you've just met muy so it's the first
part where you get to you get to play
with her at your side so it's like an
introduction and you can pick a movie
kind of like a him like a dog so you can
tell her to go places and tell her to
stop and follow you she's really a
valuable valuable companion on this epic
journey that you get to experience in
planet of lana what kind of feedback are
you getting from people that play it i
mean we've gotten incredible feedback
like yesterday and today and it's just a
big queue over at the wonderful booth so
it's just been absolutely unreal you
know five years in the making now this
game and yesterday was the first day
that we showed it to two players and
media for the first time so yeah
right let's talk about muay because she
is so cute and i can see her on screen
here just now waking up lana um tell us
about muay and what she brings to the
party
so
muy what she brings to the port as i
said before you know
lana is this like you don't have any
weapons in this game right you're
playing as this 11 year old girl and
this and this creature companion that
you meet and that you befriend she's
quite agile she can jump higher than you
and reach places that you cannot and but
you can also like fight off cables and
do things like that push down things for
you to reach and then she also has this
hypnotic ability that you might have
seen in our like game
in the gameplay trailer intro we had
just there so you gain that a little bit
later in the game and that then movie
actually can hypnotize like these weird
creatures that you come across that has
the same like glowing white eyes that
she has and that opens up just the whole
set of you know the possibilities of how
to interact with the creatures of this
world which is a lot of fun yeah great i
played the demo myself and one thing
that really struck me was the way that
movies abilities kind of you discover
them slowly and they kind of build on
each other and the puzzles become more
complex that must have been a really fun
thing to to work out as you design the
game right yeah and i think it's a super
important thing as well you know we've
been focusing a lot on like having a
good ramp up of the game you know yeah
we want this game to
like reach a really really broad
audience but it's also important you
know in this kind of games where you
have um logical puzzles because everyone
is a different level and have different
abilities of solving these kind of
puzzles so you know it can't be too easy
because that will get really boring and
can't be too
it can't be frustrating either you have
to you know balance that challenge of of
just right i think so yeah and that that
is a challenge in itself but i think
we've done a really good job did you
ever consider like a co-op mode where
two people can you know play as lana and
movie and solve those puzzles together i
mean a lot of people asked us that like
throughout development but it was a very
conscious creative decision from the
like core idea from the get-go that we
shouldn't have that because i mean we're
going for this relationship with lana
and movie that you kind of have in real
life with a with a dog like the
relationship with a human and a dog so
and if we would like
have another control and put that in the
hands of a friend to control mobile you
lose that kind of magic you know that we
feel because mu is
very much her own creature with her own
personality you know
yeah and i think that really comes
through in the
the relationship you see and hear
between lana and maui it's so like
adorable the way they communicate to
each other like tell us how you like did
that through sound design and through
the the language in the game yeah so
we're telling the story without words
right and that's something we want to do
from from from the beginning but then my
co-director and also the scriptwriter
for the game clause ericsson he invented
this language for the inhabitants of
this planet on novo and it's just it
just adds so much it's adds that extra
layer of like
a way for the characters to be able to
express emotions you know and also since
lana and movies constantly communicating
with each other so it's just uh yeah
it's it's details that like that that i
think really makes you know world
building so fun and that's something
that we really focus on in this game i
love it for sure yeah i mean it's a new
language but you totally get
what's happening like the way they talk
to each other communicate their little
chirps
exactly it's a mix of the body language
and the
language and everything yeah all right
so we talked about lana and our faithful
companion muay um but tell us about the
overall story here because one of the
things i've noticed you know in the
trailers you've got these really
beautiful contemplative moments but then
some moments with real like drama and
speed and you know these big robots as
well so what's the overall kind of story
you're telling yeah so what you can
expect playing our game is really an
epic story that will unfold over like
five six hours when playing the game and
we're really going for that's what i
think that sets us apart a little bit in
the genre like we're bringing these um
these companion-based mechanics but also
we're really focusing on on telling
quite a classical saga this story of
this unlikely hero of this 11 year old
girl
and maui going through this this
incredible journey through the planet on
this rescue mission to try and save her
sister and you come across so many
environments we have like this old
shipwreck that's been buried in this
swamp for several hundred years that you
get to explore and you get like pieces
of information that that like the the
players that have like have more
attention to detail will get more out of
the rich like back story that we've
created for this world and the lore of
the world so that's really exciting and
then
and then also all players will get an
answer to why humans are living on this
planet and why the robots have come and
why they've invaded the planet and so
forth so yeah it's really a
classic like epic adventure that you get
to experience experience with a lot of
twists and turns as well that i won't
spoil right now love that and we've got
to talk about the art style it just
looks so special tell me about your
inspirations and how that art style's
evolved over the five years you've been
working on the game i mean there's just
so much inspirations uh i mean i grew up
with games like another world and
flashback and odd world as well and
there's definitely a bit of another
world in the game as you can see and
and then yes you know studio give the
films especially miyazaki's film like
spirited away and pony on those and like
modern games like inside
but really it's just like
going for like at the start the game
actually started like with these concept
images of the game that was like
beautifully hand painted and then going
from that concept art into the game that
you have that we have today was a long
process and a lot of iterations to you
know because we wanted to create that
you know depth and immersion that we
have in the world now but still keeping
this hand-painted style so it's like
this 2.5 d
mix of you know 3d and
and and layering of 2d layers and then
and then we also have put put a lot of
um emphasis on bringing this art style
to life as well so we have this wind
system for example right there are
talented programmers that have created
where we can go from calm to full storm
and it's just you know it's it's it's
it's really we have such a talented team
and it's like it's so fun going to work
every day and get to work with these
talented people and everyone is just
pouring in a lot of love into this
project and making that's what created
the atmosphere that you can see in the
trailers and the demo that you can play
well it really shows in part of the
atmosphere is is the music you know and
you've got someone very special working
on the music scoring the music for the
game can you tell us more about that
yeah so we have takeshi furukawa that's
writing the music for the game and he's
known for creating the music for the
last guardian among other things and
he's just
like a prolific composer and it's just
been unreal to have him on the project i
mean it was very unreal from the
beginning but we just get along so good
creatively and
i mean it's also from the get-go we've
decided you know that we also want like
the sound of this planet to speak its
own language you know and then have
music come in to emphasize
um you know special scenes to like
emphasize emotions and the music also
plays like a pivotal part actually both
in the gameplay and in the story so it's
just been so great having him on board
and he's just doing an amazing job i
think thank you now you've also
announced that uh planet alana is coming
to game pass which is amazing news for
all of us game past subscribers um what
does that mean for you as an indie
developer especially with this being
your you know your first title as an
indie yeah i mean
it's i i can't emphasize how much that
means to us honestly i mean having the
game on game pass day one it will just
let i mean we're making this game with i
mean we want as much players as possible
to experience the game and having it on
game pass just lowers that barrier entry
of people to experience it so it's just
just amazing and also i just have to say
that xbox is actually played a pivotal
role in the
in the um success that planted lana has
gotten up until this point i mean we got
so much support from xbox and it's just
been really really amazing so very happy
to have that collaboration with you guys
that's amazing to hear listen we're
happy that you're here this is
absolutely incredible it's great to talk
about it um
i'm gonna hit game pass day one in
spring 2023 right yes why do we have to
wait so long adam i want to play now
yeah so i mean it was a week a week ago
we announced that we're delaying the
game we were planning originally to have
it released in this year 2022 but i mean
uh it's both both i think it's i mean
this game that we're making it just
needs to be at a very high level of
polish to to really create the the
vision and experience that we want to
create so it's just the right decision
you know i think the place will be happy
in the end that we made the decision not
release the game prematurely yeah i
think that's always a good decision yeah
i know you're quite right something
special
deserves
all the time
yeah that's great um right before you go
is there anything else you would like to
share with our audience any highlights
from gamescom or i mean
it's just unreal being here really just
just experiencing all the love and
support that we have gotten from the
game over the years and here at gamescom
and yeah just thanks for for everyone's
support yeah and very happy to be here
adam absolute pleasure okay everyone
that's the gorgeous planet of lana
coming to xbox game pass in spring of
2023 day one thank you adam for joining
us today and bringing such a beautiful
game enjoy the rest of the week thank
you so much thanks for being here
all right coming up my co-host and pal
charlie will be speaking with shyla
schofield from obsidian entertainment
about the much anticipated release of
grounded 1.0 but before that we've got
even more grounded 1.0 content to share
we're going to hear from phil spencer
himself and the creative director of
grounded adam breneke about what we can
expect from the upcoming release of
everyone's favorite backyard adventure
so what i like most about gamescom is
that i come together with different
people from around the world that i
usually don't really see very often
because we don't live in the same city
or country
and games comes the perfect opportunity
for me to finally meet them and to enjoy
video games to its fullest
what i like the most about gamescom
without a doubt is the close community
atmosphere the best thing is to be able
to see each other again and enjoy in
person side by side what we are
passionate about gaming and video games
and of course it's amazing to be part of
it and enjoy of everything that xbox has
prepared for this event thank you and
enjoy the gamescom hi everyone
i have been at gamescom twice one is a
journalist about 10 years ago and one
with the xbox team in 2019 and it has
always been very special for me i had so
much fun there and i think it's really
great to have in europe a big gaming
moment like gamescom where gamers can
meet and enjoy video games together as
well as discover new titles or even make
new friends
this year i will not be able to attend
but i cannot wait to see what's
announced at gamescom and hope everybody
enjoy it
my favorite thing to do at gamescom is
to be just outside of the booth right
when the gates open on saturday morning
and you have this crush of people you
really start to feel how big gamescom is
because it is like the running of the
bulls but like with more gamers and and
less injuries but it just shows the
dedication and the commitment of gamers
in germany and throughout europe and i'm
definitely missing that this year i miss
gamescom i'm not there this year i miss
walking around the show floor the show
floor is just massive and there's
thousands of people and just seeing what
uh what's new in the games industry
certainly i work in it but seeing it
with other fans is a ton of fun i miss
that i miss xbox fan fest of course i
miss the curry burst
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone phil spencer here really
excited we're going to get to talk about
grounded great game a game i love
playing we have adam breneke here from
the team go ahead and introduce yourself
i'm the game director um and uh thanks
so much for having me i'm super excited
to you know be here finally we're at the
end of the runway for for grounded and
it's a super exciting time yeah i mean
you know grounded is a game we've been
playing what for like a couple years now
uh started in game preview in game pass
i think it's been amazing to see
what over 10 million people have played
the game to date i've played a ton i
love it uh i'm can't wait for the 27th
of september when we get 1.0 ga story
mode all of the great things that are
coming you know to me when i think about
all of the games that we're building
one of the things i really love about
grounded is you find a passionate team
which you lead a passionate team that
has a real creative idea maybe something
that isn't exactly expected from the
studio
but you had a vision about something you
were gonna go build uh and then we could
work together foster grow that to the
point we're at now where it's getting
ready to release i think it's fantastic
it's it's wild to be like in this
position to be able to make something so
creative if this is the first time
you're hearing about grounded or seen
grounded grounded is a survival game and
you have to survive in this backyard
environment the main goal is to get home
we're at the end of our journey of
building the game and with the community
and this is the final update
for the full complete yard it's the
biggest update yet right yeah we have a
bunch of cool surprises a lot of cool
new environments that uh you know are
are going to be uh really fun to to
explore yeah the team's pouring their
hearts into it right now and uh i think
it's it's just been so fun to work
alongside the community too yeah we
built with with uh the early access and
game preview programs so many players
have given us
great feedback along the way it's really
shaped how we developed grounded right
now we're actually uh checking out the
one of the early adventure areas in the
game uh it's the hedge you're shrunk
down to you know the size of an ant yeah
and uh actually i think the ants are
bigger than you are they're a little bit
bigger right yeah
the the players right now are going
through this uh hedge maze and it's
nestled on the side of the house you're
trying to figure out like how you got
here and how you're gonna get home you
know part of the adventure is exploring
all these cool areas and environments of
the yard
one thing that we're really proud of for
our final 1.0 release is our story yeah
i think that's one thing that really
separates us from uh
most survival games and we spent a lot
of time world building adding a lot of
characters and story lines to to the
world yeah i think there's like for me i
played in game preview game pass
it was great co-op game because we get
together as our friends one of the
fantastic ways to go play build our base
i happened to go visit right around the
xbox bethesda showcase it was fun to
come out to the studio you and i getting
together
got me re-energized so i started i went
back into the game but so much had
changed
and now i'm kind of i'm so waiting for
that story mode the setting because the
story it's a great setting for a story
um kind of have a guided beginning of
the game
and then the sandbox will obviously just
open up yeah yeah for players and uh how
will you deal with like i assume you'll
have some players who will be like me
returning of the 10 million people who
have played uh when it comes out and
then you have other players who are
brand new where the idea of okay now
it's at 1.0
now is when i'm gonna go dive in like
use a team how do you think about those
kind of different players coming and how
do you design for that yeah so i think
the one thing that uh you know we want
to invite all the players that have
tried grounded um you know even two
years ago we want them to come back and
try it again and experience the full
story experience the full yard because
there's so much content yeah in this
yard it's a big open world there's so
many cool environments cool creatures to
find um but i also like for the brand
new player you know it's a survival game
first and foremost but
it's definitely a different twist on a
survival game there's one thing that
we're really proud of is the
accessibility and approachability so um
even just right now we're looking at the
broodmother fight so this is one of our
boss fights in the game where you fight
this giant spider in her spider den it
looks kind of funny because this is we
have arachnophobia mode yeah yeah and
that's one thing that's really important
to us is making the game accessible for
all different types of players we have
tons of game options so even if survival
seems you know that might be a hardcore
genre of game we're trying to bring in a
huge audience with a lot of options to
play the game how you want to play i
think that's really important to us and
we saw that in the community like
certain people just focused on the base
building and building i mean frankly
almost levels are bases that took over
the whole size of the lake which was oh
it's awesome i think you're gonna get a
lot of people who want story i think the
the boss battles and the kind of
the the circle of collecting items
building up your crew so you can go in
and take down different parts of the
game awesome people build huge
fortresses
it was an enormous amount of time
building these crazy crazy
huge forts um and then
that gave us ideas of adding more yeah
we added mushroom bricks um and
we want to add more building materials
in the future well and that loop that
you're you're commenting on now i don't
think that
it's not always recognized how important
that is is like a team has a vision
that vision meets reality of through
game pass and preview 10 million people
play and continue to play and then
they're gonna give you feedback and that
will actually change your production
schedule right because you're gonna
listen and watch what people do yeah
even even as simple as like sitting in
chairs i know that was a fun one that we
put in like a year ago yeah um that was
a huge ass just like people just want to
lounge around in their base right they
built this huge just now
yeah it's a chill right one thing for
our uh 1.0 release uh there's a couple
more surprise uh boss fights that we're
really excited about any hints or no
well we did show off the mantis yeah so
that's something that i know a lot of
players have been asking for for a long
time to fight a praying mantis and
grounded so we are delivering that
experience and uh i'm we got a couple
more uh surprises that's awesome well
congrats to the team on getting to this
point we're not quite there yet 27
september thank you i think for
everybody who's played myself included i
just love the craftsmanship and passion
that clearly the team has in putting
together such an amazing game that's a
great game to play either by yourself
with your friends
can't wait to see it come out and it's
great to be here and get to show people
more of the game so thanks for all of
that thank you
here to continue the conversation on
grounded we have shila scovered with us
from obsidian entertainment to give us
all the backyard dirt on the upcoming
1.0 update which releases on the
september 27th shiloh welcome to the
stream how are you feeling being here at
gamescom i am so excited i you know this
is something that i've missed being in
the show floor oh yeah watching players
play the game there's nothing better
than being able to get something that's
been worked on so long and getting
players to watch it so for me this is
thrilling i am there's a particular
energy in the room today as well yeah
they're not yeah oh no it's great and i
think everybody's just glad to be back
and playing games
out in public again so it's fine i
totally agree right let's move swiftly
onto grounded then as that's what we're
here for so some folks out there might
recognize it as grounded it's been
around and available in game preview for
like two years now thanks to game pass
um and phil mentioned something very
exciting in a deep dive then with adam
and that is that the full story is on
the way so what exactly does this mean
and how is it going to be integrated
into a game that players have grown pun
intended to love so much over the years
without one oh yeah no worries so
there's a few questions that you get
when you start the game and that is why
am i so tiny yes whose backyard is it
and how did i get here
so valid questions right you wake up and
you're tiny you need to know these are
important so with the story that's being
integrated into the current game play
you are going to be able to uncover
these answers find out how you got there
and ultimately hopefully be able to go
big and go home i love that that's what
they go say it's great so perfect it's
the best one
so um a reminder to fans that this is
actually going to be the largest update
that the game has had so far right yes
it's going to be absolutely huge so i
would love for you to highlight some of
both the big and the miniature because
it's grounded uh updates that games that
players can expect are coming to the
game perfect so we do have some things i
know adam mentioned the mantis fight and
there was a picture of it um it is huge
it is something that the players have
been asking for
for so long one of the most requested
insects so the fact that we could put
that in and players will finally get to
experience that fight
that's perfect i love the like of all
the games that you could find in germany
this week i do believe yours is the only
one where people have begged to fight a
praying mantis you know what and if
that's the case that's perfect i love it
so as someone who enjoys those fighters
in it the mantis is the next step
absolutely yeah along with that and like
we mentioned the story will be going in
there will be an expansion to the
backyard so there are going to be new
areas for players to explore
obviously new items to craft and
everything else
i wish i could go into specifics but
that's just something that we have a
month away so they could wait absolutely
but there have been so many updates
along the way you mentioned new
locations but it's not the first time
you've done this over the last couple
years no no no so back when we launched
in july of 2020 grounded started and it
was basically an oak tree and there were
some areas that you can go explore but
all your stuff is around this tree over
the years we've expanded to a koi pond
where we have a giant koi fish named
trudy the second
who if you look at her has a scar over
one of her eyes oh okay yes i don't know
why i asked someone once and they just
said
trudy seen some things so we leave it at
that i was going to say what happened to
trudy one as well that's the only answer
i've got but she lives in the pond
players can meet her after that we went
and we expanded the hedge which is where
the brood mother lives they can go
explore that background get some fun
stuff from there and then we went into
the haze which was originally part of
the official launch
but when we want we wanted to go back
and do it like it was there we were cool
with it but we had so many more other
plans that the team was able to go
through and redo the haze to make it
something that they wanted they added a
sandbox which has a very angry crab face
that i love because one of the first
times you get into it you're ziplining
in and you just go right past this angry
crap
so it's perfect there's a picnic table
which has a table top game that is
called uh minotaurs and myrmidons volume
2. obviously yes and so you actually get
to go through the tabletop castle that
they've built because whoever lived
there left some miniatures and
everything playing around so cool and
then the most recent one that they just
added was the upper yard area which
includes a wood pile and the termite den
so not only do you get a knocked over
barbecue pit and you get to go explore
that but now you get to go meet the
termites which are always a blast meet
the termites
so how many updates have you done now
for those who may not been following how
many are we up to um i want to save 14
which will be okay 14 will be coming
yeah as many of our fans know we do push
out our updates onto a public test
before making them go live and this is
one of the beauties about being on game
preview and working with our community
so the one that will be coming up
hopefully soon because it's available to
test okay will be 14. however i believe
i've done 18 vlogs so we've been
updating for a little while now
absolutely and it's been amazing to see
both the community and the game itself
grow so the lack of that word
momentously over the last couple years
and as well as that received positive
feedback along the side so um now we're
only a month away from the games full
release as phil mentioned on september
27th yeah i want to know what that
journey has been like for you personally
it's been amazing 18 vlogs
it's been great so when we first
announced grounded at exo19
it was a very exciting time it was a
very
you know good anxious time and
everything because grounded is not the
type of game that you go obsidian
that's perfect that's what i'm expecting
and so to bring it to exo and get a
first-hand glimpse at not only the
announcement but players actually
playing it for the first time
that was just great and so to see it go
from those few who are at that
convention grow to 1 million in the
first 48 hours
5 million in the first place
and then recently we hit 10 million
watch this grow and to watch the team
work with the community to build this
game
it's impressive like it makes me happy
every time i think about it i'm just so
proud of what this game has become to
not just the team but the community and
players oh absolutely and talking about
a whole 10 million of those players i
got to say you must get a ton of
feedback and a lot of requests so
two-part question here number one how on
earth do you go through all of that and
work through all the feedback yes so our
team is very dedicated to knowing what
the community wants and so when i say
they read everything
they read everything oh everything is
right everything they are on the reddit
constantly seeing what players are
posting what kind of faces or
information that they're sharing with
others they are on our discord seeing
what's being talked about their twitter
facebook any place that people are
talking about grounded streams they're
there to see what ideas people are
suggesting and what they can put into
the game and so in order to have that
and have a way that we can parse through
everything we have an official discord
where we encourage players to go and
join the discord and join the suggestion
channels that's a great idea it is and
it's very what's nice is it's very
community focused type of way of getting
suggestions in because they can go and
suggest something and then the community
can vote so if it's something people
really want they can vote it up if it's
not something that they really care
about they could just leave it alone and
once these suggestions reach a certain
limitation then they're put onto an
excel file and then they're brought in
front of the game director and the qa
lead and our community manager and
player support specialist bless our
hearts they go through everything with
them and they make sure that the
community is being heard in front of the
dev team fantastic so my follow-up
question on that then is i'd love to
know how the community is actually
shaped grounded over the years yeah and
if you can give any in-game examples
that actually only exist because people
have shouted so loud about it yes so one
of the ones like adam mentioned sitting
like well yeah we saw it just then in
that clips who knows sitting is what
people want in their games right but it
makes sense because we introduced chairs
and stuff and so people were able to
decorate their bases and decorate them
they did but then it would just be like
come to my base
but we can't sit don't you taste it no
no no no no no so we went ahead and we
were able to bring sitting to the game
and so now people can lounge around that
was one thing that without the community
like
without how often they requested it yeah
wouldn't probably be possible lotteries
are another one because people are
building giant houses they're building
bases um we've seen bases take over the
entire yard and sometimes they build
straight up they don't want to spend
their time at climbing a spiral
staircase so they started suggesting
ladders and we did it
a lot of the suggestions that we take
from them which are great are quality of
life suggestions yes
because they're playing the game
they know what they want in order to
make the game more fun for everyone
and so a lot of the stuff that we've
seen come for them that help are the
ability to auto pick up arrows when you
know you're gonna shoot i miss stuff all
the time the arrows fly around the
ground instead of having to go one by
one and pick them up you can actually go
and just walk over them and they're
yours saved you a click i would call
that the definition of quality of life
when it comes to a game as well love to
hear it
perfect perfect and i am curious though
what do you think is the most unexpected
addition to the game that you've seen so
far oh so the most unexpected and
probably one of my favorites um so we're
talking about quality of life and i see
this as a quality of life others may
disagree
but one of the suggestions was an
infected wolf spider
and people asked for that yes okay sure
back when we announced the haze and we
revamped it and everything else
we reintroduced new new creatures in the
yard such as the infected weevil
everybody loves the weevil this one's
better because it explodes and
there's not nothing more fun than that
oh absolutely not and then we also have
larva infected larvae and their whole
goal is just to ruin your day and
they're perfect i relate strongly to
that i won't lie they're perfect they're
they're my little babies i love them
but
we didn't have a spider in there at
first so they started asking for this
infected wolf spider and lo and behold
we have one now there you go i guess if
you want that then go for it um one last
quality live check i'm gonna go before
we move onwards um i'm sure many people
out there like myself and watching the
stream are incredibly proud of the
builds that they've been making over the
past couple years so um i just want to
double check with you can you put our
minds to ease that when 1.0 finally
releases we don't need to say goodbye to
all that hard work yeah no so the team
is very dedicated with every update that
they do to make sure all the hard work
all our players put into the game is
safe amazing obviously there are going
to be some things that we may not be
able to find because it is in game
preview early access uh-huh but that is
their number one goal today intention is
to make sure that is yes yes and so they
are doing everything that they can to
make sure that when this goes up
everything can go through your base will
still be there yeah that said i would
like to say that they would love to see
people start a new save just to
experience grounded with the story yeah
from the beginning so start over you
know
learn about this before we'll save yes
yes exactly yeah yeah because you can
keep your other ones don't delete the
other ones
keep it there no no but start a new one
and that way you can experience it and
then you'll be able to experience it
because there are a lot of players who
have been playing from day one yeah the
team has been able to make a lot of
changes to the beginning of the game to
where if they haven't started a game in
a few months it's completely different
and that's one of the things that i love
about being here is that we're talking
to players and i'm finding some who
haven't played in months they they were
just like i'm done i picked it up a few
months later and they were like oh my
god there's so many changes this is
and they've just been hooked because now
they they find some ease in the
situation without that feeling of
survival's come back again right i
imagine i mean i don't want to put words
in people's mouth but for the people who
are end game building they're in these
massive mansions they've got every
material possible when story mode comes
along they're going to be able to dive
right in and they're fully prepared so
it's whether or not people want to
really go back to those roots and that
survival and get themselves from the
ground well grounded up again i suppose
and the the thing about this story too
is when this update does come out
the story is going to be integrated into
the game so it's not going to be a
separate mode like they're not going to
go through and pick new game story mode
it's just going to be in the game like
quests and everything else
so people who have been playing will
also be able to join the story mode
without having to do any any fancy stuff
to get it to work fantastic and while
we're talking about stories you know i
have to do this so i'm so sorry shiloh
can you give us a little foreshadowing
on the full story that players will
unlock in version one you know what i
really wish i could but i know
omnipractical's technology is watching
and i just
believe it at that
that's fine you've got to try you got to
try what i will do instead is i'm going
to jump over to the topping on
everyone's lips which is the brood
mother
we saw her in the footage just then with
adam and phil she's literally right here
behind me i can see she's absolutely
stunning and we saw some of the epic
battle gameplay with said mother um and
i'm just gonna make some estimations
here is that a final boss battle is
raiding on the way can you tell us a bit
more about combat i'm so curious yes um
i love that you
just automatically go to a final boss
because she's humongous she is surely
the mother is the end of the game no uh
she is actually the first mini boss
player is going to encounter that says a
lot about where it's going as well yes
it's great um so fun fact when we first
launched the game there was a spider
that lived on a flying disc
in the hedge yeah and that was her home
players would go and disrupt her and
she's just living the best lunch
and so the dev team decided to take her
out for a bit yeah they built her a
beautiful home
and now for the price of the blt
lt blt uh bombardier parts ladybug parts
and thistles so not a bacon lettuce
tomato yes your own version love it yep
but you go and you build that sandwich
you present it to her little cove and
then she comes out and she goes oh thank
you for the food oh and your dessert so
you get to get to experience a little
bit about that yeah so tell us a bit
more about the combat then so i'm
approaching it from someone who when i
raid i'm very much like a ranged melee
type but i like to surround myself with
tanks dps healers etc is this the type
of combat you can see folks taking in
that level of strategy also to a degree
is their solo combat do you think you
could take on the broodmother by
yourself yes so the one nice thing is
although we don't say like
you could be this classist yes and all
of the kids in the game they are built
the same the way that we get to that and
allow you to kind of customize your game
is that we have mutations in the game oh
okay and that is something that you can
pick so like for the broodmother there's
a mutation called a reliable friend
and for people playing with me that is
probably the best mutation to have to
play dialogue okay i just like to go in
and charge and be like hey friend no no
you're not my friend
and so with a reliable friend they're
able to
pick someone up much quicker so you can
get back into the fight because there
are babies and ads that come in
and um that could be pretty hard to pick
someone up as you're being picked at by
a few different spiders yep no that
makes perfect sense so there is a way to
do it with friends yeah and get yourself
ready get all the equipment already in
fact is there any gear that maybe like
you've eyed up because we were talking
just before we we were saying here and
uh you actually were doing that gameplay
in the background of phil and adam's
conversation so as someone who's taken
on the brood mother themselves what's
your number one tip that you could give
us maybe to prep and think about my
number one tip is that um like most
people know spiders are afraid of fire
uh-huh and so if you get some spicy
stuff on your weapon
uh spicy spicy so we have
different modes so you can collect mints
and collect uh
transmute your weapons that way and
stuff my favorite is the spicy which
adds a burning effect to it and
spiders do not take well to that so that
is probably the best weapon you can have
okay for a range player like you we do
have arrows that are equipped with the
spicy tip so that way you can use that
to fight and you'll be good perfect and
then i could just run around the map
pick them all up again yep keep your
view off i go again
you're great stunning i love this right
um the one thing that is really amazing
about grounded in particular um is the
fact that we could talk about the full
releases coming in a month as a reminder
september 27th but like i said the
amazing thing is that you can go play it
right now yes right this second yeah so
um i want to ask you for both new and
returning fans remind people where they
can go play grounded right now yes so
grounded is currently available on xbox
game pass which i do say i subscribe to
and it is i call it the subscription
worth subscribing to i call it theft so
i'm glad we have different words for it
you know but we mean the same thing
the value is phenomenal and uh the fact
that there are so many day one games
just like grounded yep
so many of the shows we have the games
even we spoke about today as well game
has oh no it's great so that is like the
easiest way that i recommend people
because then if they're damaged grounded
there's so many other games that they
can go and explore absolutely that's
perfectly fine we're all gamers we all
want to see what's out there
if they don't want to do xbox and pass
it is currently available on the windows
store and on steam so you could purchase
it now
this is the early access game preview
price
we have announced that the price will be
going up so for people who are waiting
for story mode
before they actually go out and play
yeah i would suggest if you want to own
it buy it now take advantage of this
price otherwise xbox
and i don't want you to gameplay i have
to say that before you leave let's talk
a little bit more about the booth itself
as i mentioned we do have this amazing
photo up uh behind me with the
broodmother i'd love you to tell us a
little bit about why that's here and why
it's so important to the team to turn up
in that way oh yeah no it's just it's
great for us because we get to bring a
piece of the game for players to
actually experience the beautiful thing
about the broodmother is that she's
built to scale to scale two scales so
she is 17 feet wide seven and a half
feet tall
and thankfully we have her in a hunched
mode so she's not completely towering
over you
but it's just amazing to have that and
have that fan experience here especially
when we have an update coming out very
soon that players can go and experience
it's nice to bring them here
say hey check out grounded and then when
the update comes out they can go and
they can play with their friends and
that is something that i do want to
mention that we do with this update we
have something else that players have
been asking for and although it's not
out in the public it's out on the test
flight okay and that is shared worlds
okay interesting what's up and that
means so if you and i want to play a
game
we will by the way yes yes and you're
like you know what i have stuff to do
and i'm like you know i i want to keep
playing you can share your world with me
you log off you leave and then i can
pick up from by playing myself and then
when you come back on it you join my
game and all the progress i've made is
saved and it's just a way that the team
has been able to get players to continue
to play with their friends
and keep that momentum going because
when you get on a roll like in a
survival game and you're like we're
building this house yes and someone
leaves you're like okay i hope i can
remember what i want to get back yeah
absolutely and i think that rolls into
the whole theme we've spoke about it
fair bit but the accessibility of the
game yes and i think again we saw the
broodmother is another element that is
brought into accessibility and there's a
key word for it you told me about it and
i would love for you to say the word
yourself of what this is the danger
number
dumpling so back in the day back in the
wee days when it first came out
we do have accessibility mode and that
is something that came about because
we're able to work so close with xbox
and their teams and so they worked
greatly to figure out
why people you know have arachnophobia
what kind of triggers them and stuff
there's loads of research into it right
yeah so and we wanted to find a way in
order to get this mode playable so that
way fans could play the game who are
afraid of spiders but also still felt
like they were getting the true
experience sure and so back in the day
we called it it's still called
arachnophobia mode and everything but we
started to see some people here there
call it a danger dumpling
and it just kind of sucks so internally
that is our name
so we we love it uh some people find it
more frightening than the one with the
legs to each their own
i personally love the one with the legs
but the danger dumpling mode is also
perfectly fine just a big spider gal on
oh it's crazy
at some point i'll have a tarantula but
we're we're waiting on that i love the
goal manifest the spider it's going to
happen it's happening absolutely well i
know i need to get a picture with this
laugh so if someone could just
screenshot this
right here then maybe i've already done
it today um but i did want to thank you
so much for joining us today shiloh it's
been an absolute pleasure talking to you
um and i hope you enjoyed the rest of
the booth at gamescom though i have a
feeling they're not as spider-infested
as you want them to be so thanks again
my darling yes thanks for having me here
you're more than welcome so now that
we've explored the backyard coming up
we'll be taking a trip back in time to
the 16th century to where my co-host
maxi chats with the folks behind
pentament the upcoming murder mystery
adventure game set in bavaria in the
1500s but first we have a video to share
that might strike a little bit of a
chord
[Music]
bring it together
[Music]
now we're talking
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta help me rescue my friends
bring it down
bring it together
[Music]
bring it together now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so joining us now our game director josh
sawyer and our director hannah kennedy
to talk to us about obsidian's medieval
narrative game pentamin because the game
is set in bavaria i can finally bring
out my inner bavarian and say
nice to have you thank you so much for
joining us here thank you for having us
yeah thank you and i also want to call
out that i really appreciate that you
are the only two guests who have set a
game in germany and
so he just gave you a raise basically
wonderful no continue
he said he nice to be here but i think
we would appreciate if we stick to
english if you're okay not your nation
okay perfectly fine so um
now that
the game is set in bavaria and i'm a
little biased here because i live in
bavaria i've had my share fair of
oktoberfest but i think what's really
interesting
why did you choose that region
um i think my interest in germany goes
all the way back to my childhood
my grandmother was born in kempton on
the southwest part of bavaria and um i
started learning about my family history
and our genealogy when i went on to
college i studied german music uh later
german history german language uh
continued studying german after i
graduated uh and then so i just had this
interest in german culture and history
and i had an interest kind of in maybe
exploring that
someday through games
so now that we know where the game is
set could you tell us a little bit more
about the the when the who and give us
an overview of what pensament is about
sure pentament is a narrative adventure
game and it is set in 16th century
bavaria specifically ober bayern uh in
the fictional keersaw abbey and the
nearby community of tassing uh kiersaw
abbey is a benedict team double abbey
very rare for the time and also very
rare for the time it's still producing
illuminated manuscripts which by the
16th century had mostly been taken over
by groups like the guild of saint luke
um you play a character named andreas
mahler andreas is a journeyman artist
who is completing his fondriara or
wandering years so he's been traveling
around europe getting experience working
with masters
but he's making a little bit of money at
keersaw abbey before he returns to
nuremberg and uh
a murder happens so
that kind of throws a wrench into things
um his friend at the abbey is accused of
the murder and he basically is the only
person in the position to try to prove
that he didn't do it but he has to
figure out who actually did
so andreas mala sounds like a friendly
guy he's gonna save his friend is that
his only like friendly trade or can we
learn a little bit more about him no so
andreas is a specific character obsidian
is kind of known usually for making more
blank slate or broad characters but
andreas is a specific character in this
place in time so he comes from a family
of artists in nuremberg hence named mala
so
but his father was able to do a
commission for the rector of the
university of erfurt which gave andreas
the opportunity to get a university
education
but he dropped out so he has something
of a university education that allows
you to pick your backgrounds for andreas
um but he eventually goes back to the
artist's life the family business so to
speak um and he's just trying to wrap
things up before he becomes a master
when this kind of throws wrench and
everything
and there are a few games that are set
to play as one character for a 25-year
lifespan
so i would imagine andreas as you just
described like it's a pretty interesting
character um but could you tell us
what the fans can expect in the 25-year
journey yeah um i mean i would say again
most most obsidian role-playing games
will focus on a story that takes place
over maybe a few months maybe a year or
so it's pretty rare to have something
that spans decades of time and we really
wanted to focus on seeing how a
character like andreas who is coming
into his adulthood uh beginning his life
as a master how he changes over several
decades but not only him also kiersaw
abbey and tassing which are characters
of their own filled with
actually hundreds of characters um
interconnected families the monks the
nuns the peasants the craftsmen and just
seeing how they change over time uh but
it also it isn't just narrative it also
has a lot of impact on how we portray
that through the art
yeah so the art um is reactive to this
time that passes as well and we really
wanted to make sure that the characters
didn't feel in isolation like they were
growing while everything else was
staying the same so the scenes are
updated as well as people growing and
changing over time some people pass away
so that presented some challenges in
that we wanted still these characters to
feel recognizable like you remember them
from previous acts or they might have
been babies or children or completely
different people
but
still be
easily recognizable and still something
that you can feel attached to as well as
with the scenes you know different scene
states change as well as each of our
acts is set in a different season a
different time of year so we have
updated weather effects the landscape
changes with the time
and so yeah impacted everything we try
to make that as thorough as possible
and i really love how the game like has
set in this medieval look and that you
would see it in kind of i would say
ancient text and how did that period
time and location drive the art style of
the game directly yeah absolutely the
art style was really informed by this
period of time and real existing art
from that period
this is a historical game so we have the
opportunity to be as representative as
possible as well as this is a story
that's being told from an artist's
perspective
so we got to reference works from the
time period both to inform how we wanted
the game to look as well as
the key points of reference for
you know different information about the
characters themselves because this is a
pre-photograph
period of time so you know we looked at
existing art from artists of the period
to inform what people decorated their
homes with what types of things they
cooked what types of clothing they wore
this is all things that you can find
reference information about through text
but
when you're trying to represent how they
look um and you know find ways to adapt
that art into the context of a game it
was really useful to look at paintings
one example is that andreas mailer is
designed after specifically the
self-portraits of albert door um
you know that was not only a painting
that showed what our at the time looked
like but also how that artist viewed
himself or at least wanted to present
himself to the world at the time another
really uh core piece that we used to
reference
for building the scenes themselves was
the nuremberg chronicle that was a
really large book with lots of different
wood cuts in it that showed landscapes
and people all sorts of things so the
woodcut style from that we used that
text
really consistently throughout making
the art for the game and you can see
that those details they stand out it's
such a unique approach of the art style
of the game which is really great and
how does that
gameplay work in that environment
yeah so uh learning uh laying out the
scenes based off of that informed a few
different things definitely how the
character navigates the space we had
some experiments on what felt good if it
was going to be sort of open floor plan
navigation versus navigating on paths so
figuring out um how the scenes were
going to be
positioned and how the paths were going
to work definitely informed
how we were going to have the player
navigate the space um one example was
that we
had some challenges with uh paths going
straight up in the game felt really bad
and eventually we kind of figured out
this is because all of the reference
material that we were styling there
after they almost never show a character
head-on they never walk into the scene
space they're always shown in
three-quarter view so identifying that
that's what felt right within the art
style definitely changed the design of
the navigation and the the
locomotion within the game
and one
like definite
style really stands out to me and i
think i saw some tattoos that also have
this type of font josh like what are the
fonts that you that you are using in the
game yeah so fonts are a really big part
of the the game and the art that we
wanted to have really custom made and
bespoke for
what we were doing here
so we worked with a partner studio to
design a number of different
custom fonts for the game and we wanted
them to be different for different types
of people both in different social
classes different cultural backgrounds
and we have a peasant script we have a
special font that's just for the monks
and that process was really important i
think it was josh's kind of idea he
wanted to incorporate this to round out
the characters within the game um but
yeah i think we have six right six
different fonts i think so
yeah and they're um we also put a lot of
effort into custom features for
rendering the fonts so we have all these
different typefaces um
most of them are actually scripts so
they're handwritten and the way that we
convey that we stroke mask every single
character so every stroke of the letter
comes in one at a time and the way it
comes in it comes initially as very dark
glossy ink with a highlight and it
quickly fades and goes into the page and
dries and it bleeds around the edges
additionally people make mistakes and
they actually will make mistakes in real
time and you'll see them scratched out
and redrawn um also even things like we
use different special colors this was
all this is found in a lot of
illuminated manuscripts for example the
word god uh we'll often you'll see a
piece of dialogue written out but god
will be written last in red ink which
was the way that they would do it um and
then finally in other features that are
one printed typeface because this is the
birth of print in this era um that
typeface is actually pressed in so
everything else is written in but the uh
the drucker type is pressed into the
page and it has a procedural void and
bleed effect to represent under and over
inking the the letter forms that
actually press in
i love this details i can talk about
fonts forever i love them yeah
the whole show is going to be france now
from now on guys i'm sorry i'm sorry no
but you are making a game you're making
sure that anybody can play that game and
it is accessible could you tell us a
little bit about that feature yeah so i
mean one of the things that we found
very early on is that because of all
these special fonts and also because we
have a game with so much writing um
people were being challenged by a lot of
those fonts uh i mean they were hard
they even made jokes in that time period
about hard how hard to read those those
handwriting forms were so we have an
easy read uh
mode so at the beginning of the game or
anytime in the game you can say i don't
want the super complicated fancy fonts i
just want the easy read fonts it
replaces everything makes it much easier
to read you can scale all the text up
very large we have a high contrast mode
we also have a text to speech option uh
that helps a ton and then there are
other features for like cognitive
challenges or even just if you don't
know anything about history so i think
there are going to be a lot of people
who see this i hope and they say i love
the art style i like the idea of a
narrative adventure but i don't really
know much about germany or 16th century
so we have a glossary in game anytime
you see a term
martin luther who was martin luther
erasmus who is erasmus you'll see it
underlined and you can go into the
margin get a quick definition enough to
understand the context and go back in
that goes into your journal so you can
reference it at any time and then
because we have such a huge cast of
characters um we also found that people
were saying i can't keep all these
people straight so when a character is
not in the scene but they're mentioned
their name is underlined and you can go
into the margin you'll see a picture of
them to go like oh that's brother gee oh
that's mother uh mother cecilia now i
remember so we have all these features
in there to make it easier for people
who might be challenged by some of these
things i love that that's like the
doorway of approachability that you're
opening right there and thank you so
much for thinking of that from the start
in your games so super excited to see
those features as well and when you
decided to
create this game and have it set in the
16th century i must think you do a lot
of research i know you said you studied
german history yeah but do you work with
experts how did that go that process
yeah um i contacted a number of uh
people either that i knew because i did
go to university um for history or uh
people that i had read about so
christopher de hamel was a consultant
for us for eliminated manuscripts he's
like world-renowned for his expertise on
that and he's very helpful for
understanding how a working artist was
operating at this time period uh dr
edmund kern
focuses
well on a lot of stuff but what we used
him for was his expertise in sort of uh
austria and the holy roman empire
social structure and legal issues at the
time and then dr winston black who
specializes in medieval and early modern
medicine so we drew upon all of them to
help give a lot more layers of
authenticity to how we represented the
time period
amazing so i'm going to expect a lot of
details in there i'm going to learn a
lot i feel like i'm going to learn a lot
so even though this is a very different
type of game than the obsidian is known
for creating are there any elements that
you would say that continue the
hallmarks of the obsidian titles yeah i
mean you know we wanted to make
something that was different and more
approachable and sort of narrative
focused uh but we also wanted to give
players some choice about how they
define andreas one of the things that's
nice about saying that andreas went to
university is that you can choose
what he studied or really what he was
interested in so you know you can say i
was a latinist i specialized in grammar
so he knows latin he knows things about
the roman republic and that can come in
handiness in his investigations casting
is actually built on roman ruins we're
in cologne this is a common thing in
this region um he can also choose to say
he studied the occult because some
people don't realize that in this time
period books on magic were
largely circulated among the clergy who
were in university settings so this
gives you the opportunity to unlock
these aspects of his educational
background or as how he lives his life
for example did you live as a hedonist
where you just indulge every pleasure
or are you a businessman who focuses
specifically on making connections and
making money all these things open up
choices in conversation and how you can
go through the mystery um but then also
it's very important that you feel like
you can shape the story this is a
personal story and the story of a
community but you need to be able to
influence that
you need to ultimately decide who you
think is actually guilty of these crimes
and that's a very ambiguous thing um we
leave that open to you and it's up to
you to sort of see the consequences of
it
so it's more than just a mystery in in
general it's like really an open
environment right yeah exactly um you
know the reason why we don't call this
like a detective game even though there
are elements to it is um it's a
narrative adventure
but you are investigating a murder but
we want you to feel like um there is
ambiguity here you're not a detective
there is no forensic science so you are
investigating a number of people who
have motives and it's up to you to
really present the evidence that you
feel is
maybe the most compelling
but you don't have to you could also
just turn in the person that you don't
want to be around anymore the person you
don't like as much or it could be the
person you think the community will miss
the least but the thing is because
you're going to be returning to this
community over many many years if you
get someone punished for a crime the
people who are close to them are going
to remember that and they're going to
hold it against you maybe other people
are glad that you did that and they'll
be totally fine with it but that's
that's part of the appeal i think of an
obsidian game is that the story is more
about living with consequences rather
than a right or a wrong answer i can't
wait because that means also for
streamers when they stream the game it
can turn out into different choices i
think there's a lot to explore yeah so
what was the development like of the
process in reality
yeah so i mean i've always wanted to
make a historical game but this
particular type of game i didn't really
conceive of until about the time that
microsoft acquired obsidian um i thought
that a small narrative game historical
with a small team would be a great fit
for game pass
so i pitched my boss ferguserkart i said
i'm gonna make this game with a small
team and then i went to hannah and i
said
i have this idea for this game and i
have an idea for an art style it's kind
of blending these two eras because it's
transitional time but i don't really
know how that worked so
yeah at that point i was really excited
because this was a unique challenge but
i was coming from my concept artwork
from an illustration background so i
loved the idea of this being like a
living book uh
mixing what i love about animation what
i love about games and what i love about
books all together into this project
where we had to kind of dance this dance
between being true to history and being
representative of art that we were
looking at um from this time period with
the arts that would be eye-catching be
easy to understand and work really well
for the format so yeah i was thrilled at
that point and fully on board with this
idea so it's super obvious this game
means a lot to you it's very personal so
what are you two most excited about for
fans to play pentamete and discover them
for the first time
yeah one of the things that i'm most
excited about is this game has been kind
of difficult to clock for people to
figure out like what the genre is and
what it's all about and i think that's
really interesting like i think that
intrigue is exciting and we have this
potential to bring a bunch of different
types of people to the table people that
either might not think that they already
enjoy history or the idea of a historic
game or people that love history and
maybe don't game at all i think we have
this potential to kind of
have people learn something new in this
context and maybe expand what they
already know that they like and for me
that's that's something that's really
exciting about this project and games in
particular we're at this point now where
there's so many games so games that can
do something
new and a little bit unexpected or just
kind of confuse people in a good way i
love that how about you yeah i think um
you know this story is a really personal
story for andreas and the people in this
community and we've put a lot of effort
into all these like really funny and
cute and tender moments that uh i found
are even in this format which is is um
you know very unconventional art style
and it's all presented through text has
been really emotionally impactful for a
lot of people that have played it and so
i'm really excited to see how how it
resonates with people because um
i just think it's a very cool story and
it's also it feels like a very personal
story not only for andreas but also the
choices that the player makes and
there's a lot of really cool reactivity
that i'm excited for people to see
well people can actually see it here at
gamescom for the very first time and
we're already a couple days in today is
the first consumer day what are the
reaction of the fans
um it's been really great i mean i think
that when we announced the game like
hannah said some people were kind of
like
ah this looks cool i don't really know
what it is i'll check it out later and
so we had but some people were really
thrilled just by the subject matter and
the art so we had a lot of people coming
in and playing it who are immediately
like yeah i love this but the other
thing that i thought was cool is even
though this is a niche game
um seeing people come in who admitted
they were kind of skeptical or just kind
of like i don't know what this is yeah
they played through the whole demo and
they walked down they're like i'm hooked
i want to find out more about the story
i love it i love the presentation and uh
yeah it's really exciting to see people
play it and have a really positive
response
so last but not least when can we get
our hands on this game we're going to be
able to play it on november 15th of this
year
so once my broadcast is almost finished
i'm gonna go and play pentamen right
after that i'm super excited to play
thank you both so much for being here i
really appreciate it thank you for
having us we really appreciate it yeah
it's been a pleasure
so before we hear from the folks from
the newly announced under the wave let's
look at a totally tubular new collab
featuring your favorite dodge brawlers
and the heroes in the half shell
dodgeball
and turtles that's the level of like 90s
cool childhood me could only ever dream
about grab a slice of pizza sit back
feast your eyes on this upcoming
crossover event in this shiny new
trailer cowabunga dudes
[Music]
people of knockout city you've been lied
to
we've been forced to live beneath your
feet
it is time you saw the truth
we will live in the shadows no more
go go go
it's time for us to step into the light
the mutant mutiny begins now
hey that's me
watch your language
we can't do this alone
this is a call to all mutants everywhere
we need your help
the calvary is here
[Music]
we're here for truth we're here for
justice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we leave so many things behind us
objects
memories
mistakes
[Music]
they sink in time
touch the bottom and go to sleep
silence is full of ghosts
[Music]
and here
voices can only come from the deep
deep
under the waves
[Music]
hey welcome back everyone and whoa i
feel like i need a minute to gather
myself after the trailer that is
beautiful and emotional stuff and i'm so
excited to be sitting here with ron on
quebec who is one of the lead developers
for under the waves brought to us by the
minds behind echo and dark days this is
one i am super excited about and before
any questions run on let me just say a
massive congratulations on the reveal
must feel amazing for you and the team
to finally have under the waves out
there
hi graeme thanks a lot for your
feedbacks we were really really happy to
announce yesterday the trailer of under
the waves as we work a lot a lot on this
trailer so yeah all the team is very
happy today and we have also a lot of
really good feedbacks for so far so
yeah everyone is happy good it was a
real standout moment that trailer and
opening night live just really sean in
that show and after seeing the trailer
i've got a ton of questions i want to
dive into but let's start on the surface
okay you know give us the overall pitch
for under the weight yeah sure sir uh
firstly
um under the web is a single player on
our team driven and adventure game it
takes place uh mainly underwater in the
north bay area
and in the late 70s settings
you play a stan a professional diver
worked on an old company yeah excellent
right so i'm in but let's dive a little
deeper
my immediate reaction to the trailer
there is that there's a real kind of
emotional part to this story here can
you tell us more about that yeah sure um
so stan has keep some brief from the
surface so
firstly he decided to walk underwater to
to find some uh rest uh from the surface
to think about his own life so so as a
game has a lot of mature topics we
really work on the
atmosphere atmospheric side of the game
on the emotional side of the game so
yeah the main ideas was to create a very
emotional game yeah
yeah yeah you really get a sense of that
kind of escape and that isolation for
stan when he's under the waves it looks
amazing but i also saw some pretty
surreal imagery in that trailer as well
like things you wouldn't necessarily
expect to see under the waves tell us
more about that and how it will play
into the story yeah sure so stan
a lot of grief from the surface and also
a lot of memories to
to to
and to to
hide from the surface and um
you know as a diver you sometimes have
some disease like narcos and one day on
a routine mission stan will be
confronted with
the first strange event so at this
moment this will be really the beginning
of a journey of stan underwater and
as stan will move on those kind of
memories coming back from his past
all the game will fall into some sci-fi
things and yeah a lot of serious things
looks fascinating now i've got to tell
you run on this is really resonating
with me because you know i grew up in
aberdeen scotland right on the north sea
that north sea setting is really talking
to me my dad worked in oil in drilling
what was it that drew you personally to
that north sea setting yeah it's funny
because my father was a seller so i i
live
mainly around the sea also and yeah
for me it was a really good great
inspiration for me to talk about because
uh yeah i see a lot of things for
example about solution into the ocean so
we decided to set up the game in the
north sea because
all the north is quite polluted you have
a lot of old company you have a lot of
pollution from the second war so far
obviously we really would like to create
strong messages about ecological things
extra we decided to set up the game here
and confront stan to that kind of things
yeah awesome and it's kind of a world we
never see right under the under the
waves literally i guess it gives you so
much freedom to create an environment
for players to explore so how much will
players be able to kind of in an open
world style explore so firstly the game
is really story dragon so if you have a
man story to follow but we already
designed the game with very large area
to explore so basically you live in a
underwater but you are able ready to
swim in the under the sea you will be
able to
uh drive a little submarine uh and in a
very large area so you can really move
at your covenants in the world
but yeah you have a main story to follow
and uh in the ocean you will be able to
to find rakes to find caves we really
wanted to to let the player be free in
jerusalem to really create some
also empathy with the austrian and with
the sea life and for us it's really
important to create this connection
also to fit our ecological message
something else i loved was the this sort
of 70s retro futuristic vibe you've got
going on with the technology and the
underwater technology
why did you kind of choose that art
style and how are you bringing it to
life sorry it's all also come from my
childhood so uh when i was shy i visited
a lot of boats with my father and all
the boats were in this kind of setup and
also i was a lot a big fan of jackie's
sea documentaries and as also the
stories about reading nostalgia memories
and some stuff like that we decided to
be really inspired by those kind of
old seed documentaries so we
treat this kind of rendering we add
grain on the under pelic and under
picture we're vignetting
we had some strong contrast between
yellow and blue so we really yeah we
really would like to fit this kind of
old memories all the vintage thing to to
be yeah in a
comfortable world and
uh for us it's kind of mud lender proof
madland of cruise
yeah cool the music in the trailer is
incredible too like and such a great way
of bringing the atmosphere of the game
to life who's working on the music for
you and how are you using it to kind of
raise those emotional states yeah so the
music was composed by nicola brodan who
is also a co-founder of the studio so in
general in all of your game we work
closely with a composer with a writer so
the idea was ready to work on
emotional music to to follow the stand
stand stories to the game so we work
with all
synthetism
we work a lot on sound design too
and the ideas was ready to be
minimalistic and emotional in the music
and with also
vibes from 70s so with all the
yeah old scenes etc and yeah our main
reference where uh cigarettes are right
to read very nostalgic music too yeah
i really get the sense that there's a
lot of like personal connection to this
game with you but tell me more about the
rest of the team like how is the process
of creating under the waves yeah so we
are quite an indie team where a dozen of
uh people are very talented people for
for for
all the team and uh yeah we come from a
triple a company so with nicola brodan
the computer and sebastian renaud the
writer
we have created powerless studio to
really craft strong narrative game
because we we have a lot of
id we we had a lot of stuff memories
from on our own past
so yeah we decided to really create a
game with
many things from us
uh
it's a really personal project from all
the team
and uh yeah yeah we really would like to
have those
thing is the game here right now you've
also mentioned there's kind of an
ecological message at the heart of under
the waves as well clearly in the setting
with drilling and industry
um so how are you bringing that to life
and how are you adding that into the
world of the game yeah sure sir
mainly the idea was to focus
the story and about human impacts on the
ocean not to to be just ecological but
to create a strong also strong poetic
message about life the secret of life
because to
to to move into the life we have to be
um
we have to be confronted to seeker of
life itself and when we take some breath
from the life you we we see nature we
see
the life around us
so the idea was to create a poetic
message
uh around the story about the sea life
about the
the poetic sea life around you and
that's why we really decided to work on
ecological strong message in the game so
for example you will be able to
to find some uh strong facts about
plastic in the world and uh of course
stan will react about um
we have a lot of questions about about
his own impact as a worker of uh you
know our company
and uh to to
enhance his uh
messages we decided to find a foundation
an association
non-governmentalist session so we
work now with surfrider foundation to
really bring their messages also in the
game and to fix this message
very closely and so you will be able to
find a lot of things about yeah
surfrider in the game yeah awesome and
the work that surfrider foundation is
doing is so inspiring and i know you've
got a video to better introduce us to
them so uh let's take a look
clean water
inspired communities
this is what we fight for
[Music]
on the ground
in the classroom
at the heart of the political debate
every day we take action to battle
plastic pollution
water quality
and reduce climate change
powered by a dedicated grassroots
community around europe we are driving
change at every level
to ensure that our ocean and beaches
exist for future generations to enjoy
we protect what we love
since
1990 we are surfrider europe
[Music]
hello everyone i'm remy from south
florida foundation europe all of us at
surfrider are very excited to announce
that we are collaborating with parallel
studio and county grim to amplify our
actions of protecting the ocean and its
users by bringing our messages to their
upcoming game under the waves as gamers
ourselves we really enjoy seeing how
video games can carry meaningful
messages it's crucial for us to raise
awareness of the richness of the ocean
and its vulnerability we are very
pleased to do that in a whole new way
thanks to parallel studio and country
dream another way's message is about the
beauty of the ocean and the necessity to
protect it we strongly believe in it as
afraid and we look forward to telling
you more about this collaboration soon
so stay tuned to surfrider.edu for more
information on our mission and under the
wavegame.com for more information on the
collaboration
incredible stuff there and such an
important organization to support so
ronald tell us how surf rider is working
really closely with you on the actual
development yeah sure we we've done a
lot of brainstorming so we basically we
take a lot of facts from survivor for
example a quantity of plastic in the
ocean etc so we decided to really add
those messages and facts in the world so
the player will be able to to scan the
area and find some information we'll be
able to find a
more
more complicated uh more precise
in fact through your logbook and we have
also
done a really strong work on the
backstory of the game so one of the main
characters is directly linked to the
surfrider and so yeah
we really decided to work closely with
them not to just have a
an ecological message but ready to fix
the narrative side the poetic side and
the yeah the real experience side is
about the ecology and the beauty of the
ocean right and i think you've even got
some xbox achievements and you fired my
shirt right all right we have added a
lot of achievements uh for example
collecting a lot of plastic so we think
we think video games could be a really
strong medium for that kind of messages
and for us it's really important to move
with that id yeah totally agree run on
okay when can we play under the waves
under the wave is for next year in 2023.
excellent ronan thank you so much
amazing game looks incredible and a
really important message as well thank
you for your time for joining us here at
gamescom thank you cheers
okay
up next we're hearing about a new era of
xbox gameplay without a console yep you
heard that right maxie is standing by
with harrison hoffman from the xbox
cloud gaming team
throughout the show we have been
highlighting great games that you can
get your hands on later this year into
the next but for this segment we're
going to change it up a little bit and
welcome harrison hoffman who will walk
you through the future of xbox gaming
without having to have an xbox console
now i know i just said what i just said
but could you explain to us what that
really mean yeah for sure so what we're
showing here today is the brand new xbox
app for samsung smart tvs so this is an
app that comes pre-installed on all 2022
samsung smart tvs and all you have to do
is launch the app sign in with your
microsoft account uh pair a bluetooth
controller we actually support
both xbox as well as playstation
dual sense and dualshock 4 controllers
and you can just jump right into the to
the game to play well we're right here
right now could you walk us through a
little bit what that app look like yeah
for sure so
right here uh we're on the home screen
of the app so the first thing you'll
notice when when you come in here is we
filled the top of the screen with your
recently played games so we know from
our from our experience with with the
console that the most common thing that
people do when they come back to play is
just jump right back into something that
they were playing before so we made that
really really easy now if you want to
find something new to play you can just
kind of scroll down from here so you may
have heard recently we made fortnite uh
free to play on xbox cloud gaming so
again all you need is that microsoft's
account you can just jump right in and
play fortnite um but if you have an xbox
game pass ultimate subscription that's
when you unlock you know hundreds of you
know high quality games that you can
just play right here um inside the app
so you can see some of the the game
selections that we that we've curated
for folks here some of our most popular
games forza horizon 5 halo infinite sea
of thieves all the ones that you'd
expect and then obviously our recently
added game so we're constantly adding
new games to game pass and you know i
just kind of come in here like you know
a couple times a week and see what's new
and just and just jump right into it so
you know two point campus turbo golf
racing cooking simulator all ones that
have come out really recently here can
we jump into a game right now yeah let's
do it so let's check out grounded so uh
i'm super excited for the 1.0 release of
ground and this that's that's coming up
here and i've been checking out a bit
lately so uh let's just load up into the
game here so what's happening right now
is we are connecting you to the best
xbox cloud gaming server for your
session here um and when you're playing
in xbox cloud gaming you are playing in
the xbox ecosystem so that means that
all of your cloud game saves from your
pc or your console or your phone are all
automatically saved to the cloud so you
can pick up right where where you left
off from anywhere here
um so you can see we're we're getting
into this game and we'll just go ahead
and get the game started and uh what's
happening right here is this game is
running um on our hardware in the cloud
and being streamed down to the tv in
real time at 1080p 60 frames per second
can i try it yeah for sure so let's just
load just load this game up here and
then uh we'll let you
have a shot at it so
uh all right so here we are
at the beginning of grounded and you can
see i'm running around and one of the
most important things uh when we were
developing this app is making sure that
the gameplay feel is right like the the
latency between uh when you do something
on your controller and what happens on
tv has to be super low and you have to
feel like you're really in control of
the game so you can even see as i'm like
coming around here like how how
responsive this is like you can see i'm
just you know jumping here and it's just
being instantly reflected on the screen
um so let me actually uh let you take a
shot at this can i take the playstation
controller yeah you can take the
playstation controller so
let me let me swap controller for
microphone here
and wow this this is the first time for
me playing an xbox game with a
playstation controller but i know what
you mean like the input feels it feels
great i feel see no latency
i mean it depends on the internet that
you have at home but this is a big step
for gaming without having to have
additional hardware yeah for sure i mean
obviously uh here at xbox we have been
making consoles for for 20 plus years
and like i actually personally worked on
you know series x from early planning
all the way through launch so like
myself and a team have tremendous
respect for the gaming experience that
that colleges bring to tvs but we also
know that not everybody is going to buy
a dedicated gaming device like a console
to play so you know all you have to do
like if you have a tv that that this app
works on you just have to launch the app
and you can play so this is a
multiplayer right now like how can i
team up with my friends here yeah so uh
obviously multiplayer a huge part of
the xbox experience so that's why uh
whenever you're in a game you can uh hit
the xbox button here
i'll just grab my controller back i can
i can take this for you now we're
handling this fine we're great okay
exactly so uh you can come into the
guide here to see um all of your friends
you can see what they're doing uh you
can invite any of them into your game if
one of them invites you to a game you
can come in here to uh view your view
your invitations as well just join right
up also um achievements a huge part of
playing on xbox you've got to be able to
unlock those achievements and get your
gamer score so you can do that here all
the achievements that you unlock on on
your tv
are reflected across the xbox ecosystem
so i can come in here and just really
see what i need to work on thank you
cloud i would say yeah oh yeah for sure
uh all right how about we how do we
check out a different game
which one are you trying uh well i've
been really into this this new game
called turbo golf racing lately and this
this game is brand new on game pass it's
actually in in game preview uh so let's
just hop right in and hover into this
and this is one of those games you know
when i saw it come up on the recently
like added list you know i don't have to
download it i don't have to update this
game you know so it's just super simple
for me to just go and try it out and it
turns out that i really like it and it's
and it's super fun so so are you go for
yourself then uh
i used to be more of a golfer than i am
now but i do still enjoy it from time to
time and this is different well i can
drive but i don't golf so i got 50
chance that i'm good in this game okay
okay
all right let's just get right into
a game here so
just pick a solo map here
and we'll see what we can do
so how um often would you switch a game
in one session for example
um i mean it kind of really depends on
the mood that i mean like sometimes i
want to go and just try out a bunch of
different games sometimes you know i'm
super invested in a game that i've been
playing for hundreds of hours and that's
just kind of what i'm what i'm into and
that's just the sort of flexibility that
you get with with cloud gaming here just
being able to to jump into any of these
games uh without any hassle and you know
obviously
over the years people have gotten oh i
bounce it off the tree there uh
obviously over the years people have
gotten super used to you know streaming
their movies and tv shows from apps on
their tv like netflix and disney plus so
like we really just want to make it as
easy to stream an xbox game to your tv
as it is a stream like a show from
netflix so well it looked like you're
already pro here and you have been
dedicated some sessions to it yeah uh
struggling a little bit right now but i
swear i'm better when i'm not on camera
okay so i do have uh one more treat for
you here so
follow me this way i will follow we will
go to the next station i'm thankful
we're having two stations right here
okay let's do it what are we having here
flight simulator okay so uh what we have
here microsoft flight simulator so
obviously this game uh has a huge
history on the pc and you kind of always
need to have like you know a high-end
gaming pc to really be able to enjoy
this um well recently you know we we
brought this game over to series x as
well and it's now playable on on the
cloud so there's no big downloads here i
don't have to have expensive hardware i
can just come in here and fly and
explore so i'm just kind of coming into
beautiful
naples italy right here um
do you want you want to give it a shot
yes of course i never said no to gaming
yeah
thank you so much so folks at home if
you never tried flight sim just really
really i would recommend take a volley
copter take a hello pelican and hover
over the cities because these details
are so beautiful i have to say a sobo
did a really amazing job yeah i mean
this this game is beautiful it's just
such a technical achievement too and you
know um all of these textures are just
streaming down from from from the cloud
in real time uh from our azure data
centers and that's really what makes
this whole game possible here
and when is this coming out this is it
right now right yeah it's actually
already out so uh if you have a 2022
samsung smart tv this comes
pre-installed if you just go
into the gaming hub on on your tv then
you'll be good to go
thank you so much harrison for walking
us through this and i have to say we've
really come a long way from blowing in
cartridges wiping off our cds to get
into gaming but one thing never changed
and that's the importance of community
and i love to see how platform is
evolving lower down barriers and brings
everybody together and there's one
franchise that brings the community
together like no other and that is
minecraft i'm handing it off to my
co-host frame who's going to talk about
the upcoming minecraft legends
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is my favorite legend of the
overworld
the one i like most tells of a peaceful
land that did not know
cruelty
until it was attacked by invaders
spreading the scourge of greed and fire
it tells of a world on the brink of
disaster
rising to answer the call
of a hero
[Music]
[Applause]
it tells of struggles
and sacrifices
[Music]
but most importantly this legend reminds
us that hope
can win the day
[Music]
and that when fiery foes seem
never-ending
that
is when the world needs legends
the most
[Music]
watch out everyone the piglets are
coming and we're going to talk a lot
about those we guys but before we do i
should introduce not piglins but a
couple of the team members responsible
for the highly anticipated minecraft
legends welcome to the game's executive
producer dennis reese welcome dennis
thank you and creative director magnus
needforsh welcome magnus thank you very
much us today hey welcome back to
gamescom yeah it's great it feels good
to be back right no it's nice to be back
here in germany with sausages and video
games that's excellent
all the good things yeah at once those
are a few of my favorite things yeah
video games right so you announced
minecraft legends at our xbox showcase
back in june right so give us a reminder
of what we should expect from legends
uh well legends is an action strategy
game based in the minecraft universe
that really encourage you to go out and
explore the world
and use all of these resources that you
gather to help defend the overworld
which is being invaded by these horrible
piglets
and uh yeah it's just it's it's a lot of
fun i think the players are really going
to enjoy getting out and and playing the
game yeah
it's a new game that we're developing at
mojang
we're doing it together with blackbird
interactive
it is a little bit of a different game
because the easiest way to describe it
is action and strategy so it's a kind of
a unique combination of gameplay nice so
it's not the same minecraft that we're
used to but
clearly still set in the minecraft
universe still got all the things we
know and love about minecraft but it
must be so exciting to take that
universe in a different direction right
so why did you choose to do that with
minecraft legends
well
with minecraft
uh we really like to you know at mojang
we really like to create games that we
love to play
and we're really passionate about uh
strategy games and years ago people are
sitting around talking about how they
could bring a strategy game into the
minecraft universe
and you know the more talk more talk and
it turned into something that we really
wanted to do
that was uh it was you know it's passion
really that drove us to this legend
great
and it's kind of uh within the minecraft
universe you do kind of have this kind
of blank slate right to create all these
different experiences yeah exactly fun
to play with yeah now that's a that's
one of the great things you know
minecraft is such a treat it's like it's
for everybody in so many ways we do have
you know the original game that we
usually call vanilla we have done
minecraft legend no sorry we're doing
that now we have done minecraft onions
yeah and
now we want to bring yet another game to
broaden the experiences that player can
experience within the minecraft universe
right so once the idea or the sort of
seed for minecraft legends developed
like how did you build the team around
it who did you bring together to work on
the game well we we knew that when we
started to go out and build this there
were a couple problems we had to solve
number one
mojang isn't a strategy game developer
it's not something we do and number two
as magnus mentioned you know real
minecraft our original minecraft is
called vanilla to us and for us
vanilla is really important and the
studio focuses
mostly on vanilla
so we had to go find a partner one who
knew how to build strategy games and uh
and you know one who really had a
passion for minecraft and so we started
looking around and and we uncovered
blackberry interactive okay um they were
known for making the strategy game well
called deserts of carrack and they were
a pretty newly formed uh company at the
time but their experience ran deep with
strategy games and the more we looked at
them the more we realized how passionate
they were also
about the minecraft universe we really
thought they could be a great partner
for us and so that's when when we
started moving forward right
and
when we started to work with them they
also you said they were already
passionate but they were also eager to
learn what yeah what's the secret behind
making a minecraft game so it's been
super interesting to work on them like
their creative team just you know
tossing ideas around and could it be
this no could it be this yeah a great
idea and we're kind of just
you know throwing ideas back and forth
what's good for minecraft and what's not
good for minecraft right it must be
great to bring new people new ideas into
that kind of minecraft melting pot that
must be a ton of fun right oh so much
fun and actually you know the team
started very small uh just a you know a
few of us kind of getting going and then
once we had a good idea as to how we
wanted to progress
it slowly got larger and larger and then
you know new people with a lot of new
experience came on board and i remember
magnus actually magnus came on with two
three years ago and uh and when he came
on
his experience with open world games
completely changed how we wanted to
think about legends and we were able to
take a lot of his experience and apply
it to legends to really create a better
experience and i mean and that's the
story across the board with lots of the
folks from uh from you know the team as
it grew and it's i really enjoy it it's
been it's been a great experience oh
magnus
well thank you
it's a pleasure to work with them and
you know the whole team is fantastic to
work then as danny said i come came
aboard a couple of years ago
but i also saw the energy that already
existed there like everybody was so
excited and it was a great to you know
for me to learn
a new environment and a new type of
games like come a little bit from a
different background yes i made open
world games i can bring that experience
but minecraft is so different so it was
a lot a lot of
super fun learning for me as well coming
to mojang you know really get
of course i played it almost since day
one because you know back in the day
they were mojang was a studio across the
street from me so like
we we've known it i known it for a long
time but just you know getting to know
it for real working with all the
creative people those at mojang but as
well at blackbird you know just
that's that's what i like to do as you
know my in my creative leadership i kind
of like to do
leader teams you know just get them
together but there's so much
creativity going on and
you know get that
snowball effect just talking about ideas
and so on it's so fun
he even listens to me
executive producer every once in a while
every now and then every now and then
that's amazing no speaking of the team
now one of the things that fascinates me
about this is that blackbird are in
canada right yeah magnus you're in
sweden yes dennis you're in redmond near
seattle right so you've got three
completely different geographical
locations how do you pull all that
together uh well it's you know a lot of
work and dedication from the team in
general
but that's the thing we've we've managed
to uh change our hours when we need to
uh and you know also bbi has been very
accommodating when we all need to travel
to a location and be on on site work
together we just make it work
but really it comes down to that passion
and working together let's say it's fun
we really enjoy each other's company um
and you know what start us as just sort
of work relationships really has become
more friendship and so you're willing to
endure some of that time zone change so
that you can you know enjoy
spending time i stare at magnus on the
screen so much
yeah you're crazy you kind of like i
don't know when you go up we often go
for i normally go to bed so i don't know
yeah but you're up pretty late too so
we just make it work yeah exactly
but yeah no like making games is always
a bit of challenge like it's
it's not easy to make these kind of
games but
it i i think it's it's an all that
struggle that you as dennis said you
make friends in in real life and so on
and just get along together and have a
good time
you know
struggles makes people come together in
a good way yeah absolutely so you talked
about minecraft legends as an action
strategy game right why did you choose
that genre and um you know tell us what
that means from a gameplay sense
well
so what we we wanted to make sure that
uh when we choose it any games within
the minecraft universe
that uh you know they're unique and
different and really you can look at
legends for example we we did that where
we uh we wanted to bring a dungeon
crawler experience into the minecraft
universe and so in doing so we wanted to
make it feel very minecraft and and
that's that's what we did with the
strategy game here with with legends is
we really wanted to make sure that we
are authentic to what minecraft was as
we bring it into you know a strategy
experience into the universe
and you know i mean that's
what danny said
in the beginning it was an idea that hey
we should have a strategy game within
the minecraft universe and that would be
cool but another aspect of minecraft is
that we all always have a hero character
so the hero character is there and
that's not common in strategy games you
usually
control a strategy game by a mouse
pointer or something like that right so
bringing that hero like letting the
player feel like they're part of the
game world is super important in all our
games so
that kind of founded hey how can we
combine these two types of game where we
are one part hero centric with one part
controlling armies and so on it's
that's really been really interesting
and when we kind of started to realize
that
it's hey this is quite new and as a game
maker when you find something you feel
um this isn't
like there's not 10 games like that out
there then you feel like you're
something on to something special so
actually it was
the thing that brought me really into
this project was kind of my first day
two of the team members just sat down
directly described the game to me and i
kind of like all in
almost in that day felt like wow we have
something great here because i haven't
heard anything like this before and so
and then we just kept rolling with that
action strategy idea okay this might
sound like a silly question but right
action strategy where do you find the
balance right because action is quite
immediate it's quite visceral strategy
is a little bit more step back assess
the situation so where's the balance in
legends
it's uh it's hard to balance games
always but
i would say
it's hard to draw a pie chart of you
spend 73 percent in strategy mode and
this percentage in another mode and so
on but
it's
it's like
i'm surprised how well it actually fits
together now like the because they go
into each other and they complement each
other in really good way
one thing that we wanted to do from the
beginning is to make a strategy game
that works well on console right
that's hard with the traditional like
but it's actually
strange to think about it but the pace
of a strategy game is often higher than
an action game because you're so quick
of scrolling around
maneuvering around with your cursor and
so on click click click and you do
very very many actions in a very very
short time in a strategy game normally
so having a hero at the center that
can't be there there there there
actually
surprisingly enough brings down the
tempo of a strategy game which is very
well suited to make it play well on
consoles by a controller so like just
adding those two types
it was kind of a surprise i wish i could
be smart and sit there and say yeah we
thought about that from the beginning
but sometimes you need to be honest and
say this that's something that we
discovered as we prototyped and
developed the game and what happened
yeah
yeah exactly
that's one of the things i find really
interesting about this is you know you
made the point you're not controlling a
cursor you're actually controlling a
character you have to deliberately
traverse the environment and you know
physically move within the game right so
how do you handle that within the game
design like actually getting around the
world
uh well it was actually really great
because it's easy to navigate as you go
about and and run through the world you
are on a horse uh within minecraft uh
you know that's possible in vanilla but
um but here you're always on your horse
right so you're able to navigate all
types of terrain quickly get to where
you need to execute your commands
and then
also there's other areas in the game
that you as you're running through the
world you'll uncover new elements like
for example we have speed wheat which
gives you an instant speed rush
or actually mushrooms within the world
which allows you to jump extra high and
then you can use those abilities to
access other areas of the world in uh
you know quick or uh you know strategic
ways
oh and let's given that you've gone in a
slightly different direction here a
different genre
you know what inspirations did you pull
from within you know other things you've
done within minecraft as well but then
maybe some external influence as well
other games yeah well
for me like i really look not to
external games to to make this reference
but more internal like
you know
dungeons minecraft dungeons
taught so much to the art organization
on to how to bring
a new game that is not your traditional
minecraft experience a dungeon crawler
uh to uh the players and
like i i personally think we learned so
much just from that game alone that
we're applying the legends to make sure
that we can bring another game in the
right way i would definitely say that's
a great reference
yeah
well inspiration on the creative side
obviously as you mentioned
minecraft in general like we yeah all
our games we want to stay true to
you know creative people are so fluffy
and it's hard to tell but that minecraft
feel
it's like hard to describe in other ways
otherwise but you know it immediately
exactly we know it immediately but
other than that it's i don't want to
play point out this special game because
as we have been talking it's kind of a
unique combination it's not like any
other game out there
that's rare it's but of course there was
a few games like this in the 90s in the
early 2000s not very many but technology
now makes it too
possible to push that even further we're
having more troops and so on
so i can't say there's a one game or
several games but you know just play a
lot of games and enjoy them and you will
draw inspiration for so many things
one thing as a creative i think it's
unusual to hear that people but it's i
like to think about you should throw
inspiration from things that you don't
think is that good either so when you
play games that you feel like
i'm missing something here what can i do
to make this a better game as well so
it's kind of strange to be inspired by
bad things but that's actually true for
myself yeah that's a super constructive
way to be inspired right it's building
on something that's awesome so when you
think about the player you're aiming for
is it more of a the sort of classic
minecraft player or is it more of a
classic strategy fan uh yes yes it's all
over the above yeah you know that's
that's one thing is that we really
wanted to create an experience
that if you're not a strategy game
player that you can enjoy right and if
you are a strategy game player then you
know we'll we'll give you a great
experience that you can enjoy as well
and i think that we're really nailing it
like we're actually it's it's coming
along uh i was not a traditional
hardcore strategy game player but i
found myself really really enjoying
what we're creating to the point where
i've started experimenting so i'm
playing some other games now and it's
kind of broadened my
my exposure to the genre and so i have a
feeling there's going to be a lot of
other players you know similar to me
right yeah
it is has been important to obviously to
get a as a broad target audience as
possible but i think again with
minecraft
it's possible because we are already
reaching out so reaching so many players
and so on so obviously
all the players who knows minecraft now
get a new way of enjoying minecraft but
at the same time it's super important to
remember that
even though a lot of players play
minecraft or have played it in the back
like past and so on
this game is also totally possible you
don't need to have played minecraft you
don't need to know what minecraft is to
enjoy this game you can come out come in
and this game will help you to
understand what the minecraft universe
is and bring you into the wonderful you
know thing we have going on there
excellent i want to talk more about the
hero we touched on the hero earlier yeah
i just find it really fascinating like
how did you center the experience and
this idea of action strategy around that
hero character
uh you know the hero coming into the
world and that element of uh exploring i
mean that it's it's very minecrafty
right so applying it here was just
something that we wanted to make sure we
did
uh and i don't know magnus you could
probably touch on a little better
exactly
i should say the hero is important but
it's it's kind of like because it's
important in all our games like that's
the center we want that to be a
a you know a
extension of a player almost right
so the kind like
the there is a story told about hero
coming into that led this legend and so
on but the game structure is relatively
open so you can play it however you want
in the order you want to and so on
we'll push on the stereo the story
depending on what actions your take with
your hero
so you move through the story in the
campaign
but at the same time as we want that to
be the core of the game it's not in game
play everything it's so much more about
that you are a character coming to this
world
and you know uniting everybody who is
here
against the threat
that the piglets are so you need to come
here to make a lot of friends
and they will together with you help you
to defeat the piglets so
it's it's not about getting stronger or
you're not getting a new arm or anything
like yeah it's more or less make friends
you know play around with them have a
good time and defeat the piglets
together
it's a great message though isn't it
it's like it's almost like you're
building connections you're building
alliances you're uniting yeah exactly
against the common enemy i didn't think
about this but i said before like it's
kind of like game dev i said like
struggles makes you come together and
you're able to overcome obstacles and
that's kind of what you do in the game
as well as the hero yeah yeah there is a
struggle the picklings are attacking we
need to defend so the everybody comes
together
and then we defeat the piglets and i
love that and it's with your team as
well yeah you know you're bringing this
team together from lots of different
places yeah very very very cool all
right it's time to talk piglets ah yes
we wanna talk piglets i mean what's
their deal and why did you choose them
as the bad guys what's up with them
what's up with the piglets uh you know
piglets exist in vanilla yeah um and
they yeah they were great for us to
bring them out into legends and expand
on them and so you know there's there's
sort of different versions of what
piglens exist in legends uh compared to
what they are in vanilla but they're you
know these
horrible mean kind of ugly cute
characters that look like they really
stink
but
it's just they sort of invade and
they're just causing nothing but
problems and you know here they are in
the overworld destroying it and that's
where you the hero comes to play to try
to you know unite that overworld and
take them back and yeah that's uh
definitely a big piece yeah they as you
said they are ugly cute right so they
they're so charming and we felt that
from the beginning like of all the mobs
that we have we like all our mobs in the
minecraft universe but the pickling had
such a potential to be kind of like the
bad guys
in the game where you it was easy to see
wow we can make this version of a
pickling wink with that marlin so we
have expanded the the range of picklings
in in many different ways you saw the
trailer when we started up you many new
types of pickings within the game and so
on so it's it's pretty cool so tell me
about some of those different types of
pickles i want to know what we're coming
up against well we actually there's one
of them we just uh just debuted here in
the trailer that you just saw
is called the picmodillo and uh yeah
it's the one that comes out of the
portal and then kind of hunches up into
like a cube and rolls at you
very difficult to defeat and uh one of
the more fun ones yeah
another one is the bruiser it's uh it's
another one you've seen in the trailer
it comes out and has like two kind of
razor blades on its arms and does you
know some really wicked moves as it as
it comes and attacks you uh but yeah
that's that's a very fun one too
there's lots of different types of
piglens yeah we have expanded in so many
ways so that's a couple of
like detailed units another thing that
we have done is you can like build up at
almost like a society like we have
different boards as we say here is game
comes we have been presenting a port of
the bastion
and so the different hordes
differentiate both in look but primarily
in the game how they play how you play
against them and so on so they you need
to like
think about how you engage in combat
with the different words in different
ways yeah so
they look and feel different and it's
just fun to engage with them right so
what kind of units do you as the hero
player then bring to bear against the
piglets
well i mean for example uh you know
magnus referenced how the the uh horde
of the bastion has wireless structures
so one of the students one of the units
you're going to want to use on your side
is one called the cobblestone golem
that's very good against structures so
you can take the cobblestone golems and
attack and get a lot a lot more uh
results a lot better results another one
is the plane golem uh you saw a horrible
demise of a plane column uh in the
trailer actually but that's one of the
ranged units and uh that's very very
good as you attack to use those in
tandem
uh i don't know any others you can think
of well i'm thinking more about the way
that you need to engage with them
because they as i said the ports are
playing differently the horde of
sebastian for example
it's almost here without the name right
they like to build forts they entrench
themselves and so on so you needed like
grind your way into their bases and to
defeat the portals at the center of it
while others are more open and so on so
how you think about your unit
composition which friends you bring with
you in each fight and so on
and also the way you lead them like you
can
you can lead your friends
into battle in so many different ways
yeah
i love exploring the bases yeah like
take a hike get to the high ground look
at the base and evaluate what is the
best way i want to attack this space
yeah and then use the tools your units
as you see fit to go and do the best
results possible yeah it's it's good
variation right
so a lot of gameplay variation a lot of
different units we will show more as we
go along yeah up until launch of the
game so it's great you know as you're
talking through there
it feels like yes you're taking the
genre in a new direction but it's also
giving you a new direction to talk about
the lore
of minecraft world and the mobs that we
already know and maybe love and finding
out more about them is that is that
right
yeah absolutely it's uh
like part of that minecraft feel like
talking about you could call that for
lore but we want to have a little bit of
a mystery going on around what's you
know what's going on in minecraft and so
on and that's that's how we work with it
so
we are kind of like
doing things in the different games
where you can find hints of what's going
on in another game and especially our
community they're so good at kind of
like trying to figure out what we want
them to figure out and so on like so we
bring some secret messages and then try
to decipher them yeah all the time and
it's like i want to be clear when we
announced the game
i mentioned that
or that uh jens had a shirt on
which was a hint as to what badger
became today none of us
are wearing any sort of hints about
future games so just letting you know
i've been very closely examining my
features
trying to figure out
take a freeze frame of that everyone
yeah
all right amazing magnus dennis thank
you so much for your time it's been
great just to talk about minecraft
legends
when can we see more when can we hear
more
it's uh well you can learn more by
following us our all our you know social
channels twitter so on you can also at
minecraft.net follow up on a newsletter
so you will get that wow that's loud
yeah
i don't know
yeah microphone
all right
live yeah well later this year we will
have minecraft live great we'll come
there and tell quite a bit more about
the game so okay more secrets to reveal
more secrets to reveal
fantastic hey brilliant seeing you both
welcome back to gamescom thank
thank you thank you all right before we
close out the show with learning
everything you want to know about age of
empires maxie and i had a bit of fun
walking around the booth earlier today
so let's take a look
it's so exciting to have a physical
foods bag great how do you feel i love
it it's so good to be back we're three
years away but it's amazing we're here
we're back at gamescom and the best
thing is communities all getting back
together again we're playing some games
it's great and we want to show you that
boost so let's start here what do we
have right here well yeah i mean lots of
change in the last three years but sia
thieves is still here season seven just
released so much good news stuff in
there and of course you can play it on
the show floor here at our booth but
there's more as well right there is more
and we're going to check it out right
now let's take a look
hey you can't be a proper pirate without
some pirate ink so welcome to the sea of
thieves 2 studio here oliver how you
doing tell us what you're doing yeah i'm
pretty doing pretty fine um basically
we're doing amber's tattoos so you can
choose um any of the game designs
achievements thingies and have them
spray painted onto your arms heads legs
whatever shirts keep up the good work
and maxi i think you got one done
earlier right finally i can break off
it's amazing it has glitter on it i
really recommend glitter i don't think
it's gonna get any better than this but
let's check out the other stuff okay
let's do it
this is really amazing if you want to
have a memory to take to your home you
can do photos vote opportunities you can
do a short video and this one is a sea
of thieves version absolutely so we
better give it a go right yeah let's do
it three two one
so this is a trigger warning if you have
arachnophobia close your eyes right now
absolutely there's no danger dumplings
here folks say hello to the grounded
brood mother
these guys don't look too scared though
it's totally fine it's only fine so
grounded 1.0 is going to come out in
full campaign mode with the first boss
encounter the brute mother on the 27th
of september on xbox game pass right
right here that's correct
oh my god it just touched me frame come
on let's get out of here let's go i like
it
now one of the most exciting games on
the booth especially for the german
crowd is pentamen right maxine yeah
especially for me because the region is
set in bavaria and bavaria is my home
state i live in munich and it's obsidian
medieval narrative game and you play
andreas mala over 25-year lifespan and
just solve mysteries great but listen
there's even more to play let's take a
look
[Music]
you see so what do you think is more at
play it is it is i see you suck at
parking like your frontier planet
atlanta inclination amazing it's great
isn't it and in the 18 plus area over
the back we've got a plague tail requiem
and we've got benedict fox and then of
course the game that everyone's talking
about lies of p and it's coming day one
to game pass right but that's not it we
even got more to play so if you're here
super excited and let's go on with the
three it's great to be back everyone
we'll see you soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
there's more than one way to win a
battle and every empire must find their
own path to victory
whether you strike from afar or ambush
up close
the malians will use wit and strategy to
out maneuver their opponents and gain
the advantage on the battlefield
with powerful speech tools and the
ability to rally large formations the
ottomans can keep the pressure on to
bring down their enemies defenses
[Music]
when the drums of war beat how will you
emerge victorious
[Music]
history is in the making
and your place in it has just
begun i swear i could watch that trailer
three more times at least but alas we
are coming to the end of the show today
so we wanted to make sure we go out with
a proper bang or in our next case an
ancient battle and what better way to do
that than to talk ancient conquest with
burt beekman studio head from forgotten
empires hello and welcome bert
hey charlie good to be back at gamescom
after all these years with age of
empires absolutely yeah and i don't tell
you what before we dive into anything i
do want to ask you how good it feels to
be back with the german fans because i
know how much age really resonates with
them is amazing like there's such a
massive fan base here in germany like
just walking around
all the halls with your age vampire
shirt yeah people are just stopping
you're like wait eight where can i play
where can i find that
they actually they have stories to tell
as well like hey i played this for years
i played as a kid yeah i'm still playing
it it's it's amazing it's such a such an
amazing franchise and i have got to say
we did do xbox fan fest last night and i
was over in the corner playing it for 90
minutes instead of talking to anyone and
i don't regret a second it feels at home
when i'm playing age you know it's just
so lovely and warm a perfect good use of
your time yes yeah that's what i think
right okay let's dive into it and start
talking about it from there so um in the
trailer we just saw we saw that there
are two new civilizations on the way
joining age of empires four and they are
the ottomans and the malians so we're
going to talk about both of them but i
want to kick things off with the
ottomans so yes what have you got to
tell us about them uh loads so good
let's let's let's start with the history
because in the end everything in age of
empires is grounded in history right yep
uh so we're looking at the ottoman
empire uh what was all happening anatoly
in the middle ages yeah uh and uh yeah
if you think about that it was an empire
that lasted a very long time it was very
based on military very militaristic very
organized a lot of military science
going on very regimented army
that really controlled a massive area in
the middle east for a very very long
time okay uh and then the question was
how do we turn that into a game yeah how
do we turn that into age of empires uh
and it was really like okay we have all
this military piece yeah that's that
sounds like something we can translate
and i actually want to dive straight
into the gameplay um
so for example the ottomans they have
the military school okay
a brand new building they can build it
in the dark age uh straight from the
beginning straight from the beginning
okay i don't know what this building
does here but that sounds like a game
changer that it's immediate okay
actually a game changer absolutely
absolutely um so you built a military
school and it automatically trains a
unit that you select like you have all
toggles for all the units in the
ultimate roster wow and you can select
which one you want to create
for free
i feel like there's a butt coming though
right there is a butt coming there is a
butt coming the training goes very very
slowly okay but i suppose the sacrifice
of a slow training is three armies you
still get the free army yeah
those folks who want to go for combat
victories if you're not draining your
resources you can just build this well
this massive empire of meanies because
everyone out exactly yeah so it's and
that's also kind of how the ultimates
play out like you jump into the game as
the ottomans and it's really all about
the military and the military conquest
and winning true
very military means that's that's how
you win as the ultimates yes uh what's
also nice about the ottomans is like the
first time i i played it like a pretty
advanced version already
it's like you feel straight at home like
you have played other age of empires
four civilizations and they're all quite
different from each other yeah but you
get the hang of it quite quickly yeah so
it really resembles the rest you feel at
home and there's not a steep learning
curve on it not not too much though oh
okay so can you tell us any more about
any of the military units or any of the
buildings
so we have the the military school right
and they can't trade all the units and
they have quite a few unique units as
well uh-huh uh first they have the the
janissary uh a bit of a fan favorite
like the chinese state was in age of
empires too was an age of ambassador iii
uh it was always like the way that the
ottomans got their gun powder any uh
earlier than any other civilization in
the game advantage yeah oh yes yep uh
and it's the same here in hvac source or
continuing this tradition yeah they can
build a area it's a hand candle near
that they create in the castle age so
before anyone else
uh so yeah you can uh yeah rush to your
guns yeah they really do they definitely
have that combat edge right oh yes oh
yeah
amazing so what i want to know though is
if i was to go over that booth over
there or when i play it when it comes
out what's the strategy behind them is
it literally just to build an empire
constantly or is there a pace to it how
would you recommend fans approach it
there is definitely there is one
completely novel thing that the ottomans
have and it's the imperial council and
that will play a big big part into your
strategies and how you kind of play the
the ultimate civilization uh the
imperial council is kind of as you built
your empire no matter how like
researching technologies going to the
next age training units um you kind of
gain experience i say experience points
uh you get uh viziers
look at your empire and say like this
has my approval i shall grant my uh
services to you yeah uh and those
viziers can then say okay i'm gonna give
you tactical advantages like hey um i'm
gonna
make sure that you can conscript some
janissaries from the town centers and
you can use those to your advantage in
your next uh attack oh okay it's really
like you have to pick like do i go for
something more military go something
more economical i think more building up
yeah a lot of options there and i know
you guys like to do something a bit zany
so is there anything a bit different
about the ottomans any other characters
we want to talk about there is
definitely one unit that is a bit
different from everything else i hope
you're going to say what i think you are
uh we we have the master coming up and
apologies for my turkish accent there
but it is a uh it's a cavalry unit yeah
but he doesn't fight uh but he makes
sure that people around him fight so
it's a it's a drummer cavalry
and depending on the the beats he's
drumming yep uh he kind of has an aura
around him to improve nearby units okay
so if he's doing like metal music or
drum and bass everyone's getting a
different vibe and going forward yeah
exactly like i don't know yeah with rock
music you go faster with metal music you
get a bit angry i mean so it'd be like
an attack buff wouldn't it if you put
like some like slipknot drums on or
something there we go there we go
very angry gemstones next to you but yes
very very good okay wonderful so we're
going to jump from them now to the
mallions do they have any little drummer
boys but if not what do they have going
for they have a lot
but a lot going for them
i i kind of want to start in the history
again so 100 this is a game about
history let's always
yes
so when we look at the malians the
malian empire actually was a
massive empire in western africa
their famous the most famous malian ever
was mansa musa and the reason he was so
famous is because he was the richest man
to ever have lived in the history of
humanity oh wow well up until like even
now or just until now until now can i
just say this is literally better than
going to school i learned so much about
history playing this game it's absurd
there are stories about him that he went
to uh he liked to travel yeah like he
liked to trade with his straight caravan
through the deserts and visit uh towns
and he was known for going to those
towns
uh spending so much gold because he had
so much gold
he completely crashed the economy of any
village that he passed
so that's one samusa anyways
it's it's a nice background to have
because we're talking about all these
gold yep and the malians are all about
gold
um when you build up your empires the
malians you have this special building
called the golden pit
and you can build it on a gold mine
and then automatically extracts gold
from the gold mines automatically yes
you don't need villagers and it also
doesn't subtract gold from the gold mine
so technically it's an infinite gold an
infinite gold hack it is
yes but it's not a hack it's actually
you've just put it in the game it's not
a bug it's a feature so
uh famous words yes uh that's huge
though especially for some of the late
game builds where gold comes into play
really heavily or if you're in a map
that's absolutely infested with enemies
and you can't get to the next gold mine
that's that's humongous wow there is a
catch however there's always a catch
always there's always a catch but yeah
i'm so sorry uh you all
you can build those golden pits like the
the pit mine story all over the map uh
but you need to be able to protect them
well of course and that's that's quite
difficult i feel like if i was an
ottoman up against somalian i would go
for that first you would but then the
the the ottoman is trying to rush you
and then what so it's it's like this you
you get the golden the the pit mine
story yeah all the way out in the map
how are you going to protect it it's
very very hard and this is where the
strategy of the game and this is where
yeah
and fro exactly so can you tell me any
more about uh any buildings or any new
units we're going to see with the
millions the units it's i i
we don't have time to go through all of
them unfortunately
every single unit for the malians is
different
uh it does they don't have a standard
roster okay i say that they have a
standard archer that's it
we'll give them an archer everything
else is different uh they for example
they have a spearman uh that is uh
actually donzo is their name uh it's a
unique spearman it's different because
he has two spears now i like them
already you like them already but um
there's more to it it's not just like
he's fighting with two spears but he he
takes his first spear throws it yeah so
the first arranged attack and then he
can fight uh the rest of the game and
there's no animation for him to go pick
it up or anything unfortunately not it
will be brilliant i'd love to see that
but uh or if you missed any ads oh god
though let me go get it again or if he
misses it like oh come on
that's brilliant okay i like the sound
of that do we have time to talk about
buildings though you've got to give me
something on buildings i only give one
more unit and one more building because
they're actually very interesting uh we
have the
musafadi
musafadi is a uh
it's kind of a hunter
unit okay and uh her special ability is
that she is uh she can go into stealth
mode oh interesting all right so it's
kind of this metadorm unit that can go
into stealth mode sneak around the map
everywhere and then just like surprise
attack are we talking like bog of war
stealth or when when they're in forest
units at stealth or so yeah age of
empires indeed has a stealth forest but
this this unit she can go into stealth
anywhere on the map anywhere okay as
soon as she attacks of course she
reveals herself so well yeah yeah it
smells like ghost spoken
fight url no no
then they reveal themselves yeah uh but
yeah that's that's kind of the story
behind the hunter the hunter woman
actually mussofati like is malian for
power woman so we have a i love them yes
okay and you say that they're aligned
with a building in game as well yes
indeed so uh they're hunters that's kind
of their background uh and you can also
one of the landmarks that you can build
is the hunter fortress
and every infantry unit that is kind of
around this fortress also goes into
stealth mode
so i don't even know what to say about
that is that something that you found in
your historical textbooks is that people
would disappear around it what was the
logic behind adding that the the story
is kind of like they were hunters if you
want to hunt and you want to yeah hunt
your prey you of course you need to be
sneaky you need to be stealthy
exactly yeah
and that's kind of the story behind that
uh it's very interesting to play with
yeah no i can imagine i'm i'm thinking
about this is me imagining me playing
the game now if you were to go and
attack that base you'd see this stealth
fortress and you would have no idea what
was waiting for you absolutely
the limits of how many people you could
hide in that radius to go there get yep
yep
amazing so um we spoke a little bit well
actually i'd say we spoke quite a lot
about the malleus and ottomans sounds
like there's more to come um but they
are they've been they're new to age of
empires but the list is pretty long of
how many civilizations there are now
right yes we we're now with 10
civilizations yeah so we had eight
civilizations that launched last year we
had the the the english the french the
mongols chinese
uh
many more in europe and asia and now
we're expanding to africa with tamales
and the middle east with the ottomans
you're probably gonna say these dudes
are the new ones but i'm curious do you
have any personal favorites or any
civilizations do you think you've played
the most i
you know i mean
i really really loved play testing the
mullions because there's one more that i
really really loved about playing them
um i i built this whole empire right
without my my trade routes my gold mines
my little mining towns
and at the end of the game okay i won
against ai i'm not bragging but a win is
win
uh i i
i looked at my empire at the end of the
game and i was like this looks good this
actually looks like a big maldian empire
and it felt so good that you've built
something yeah you destroyed something
of course yeah but it's like the victory
felt even better yeah no future i think
aesthetic goes a very long way i would
love for you to start grading us on the
aesthetics i'm very purposeful when i
build about where i put everything so
i'm like oh a normal village wouldn't
have a house here
i've got to do my little housing area
and a little suburb and whatnot so
exactly i'm totally with you on that one
but i yeah i totally agree the way that
you could just build and create very
realistic authentic villages is
incredible um i do want to touch a
little bit though on the fact that it
has been 10 months since age of empires
4 came out um how much has the game
evolved since then
uh relic and and all their death
partners have been incredibly busy so
there have been many updates many
patches uh in in many various ways like
we've had features new features coming
in like we've had uh color pickers for
people we had more remappable hot keys
we've had loads of balance changes we
had new maps uh
new zoom levels like i i yeah loads the
list just goes on and on and on and i'm
going to take us back in time now if
there's anyone out here who didn't know
the age of empires was first released in
yes and i'm curious how the developers
keep building on a franchise to keep it
new and fresh when the focus is on
history it's just so incredible it's i
mean there's just so much world history
and and
anything goes in age of empires like if
it's if it happens we can probably put
it in the game in some way yeah and if
we're just looking at uh the last
12 months like we've had the release of
age of empires four we've had two
expansions two dlc's for age of empires
two definitive edition and two dlcs for
age of empires three definitive editions
wow so it's and the fact you've got
definitive editions as well
people want so much age
people want so much age
there's more and more age to come so
that's we've got that squared away and
it's
also thinking about like the franchise
has been going on since 1997. 25 year
anniversary right exactly yeah yeah
the fact that uh like this is
if anything the best time to join age
vampires because there's just so much
going on so even if you're like hey 25
years i've never tried it try it now and
i will say it's a very wholesome game
with a community that's deeply devoted
and beloved the game so much um and i
wanted to ask what it's like to work on
a franchise that it's not only positive
we've seen so many games just on the
show today that everyone loves is really
positive but you're with someone that's
been positive for 25 years people love
it what's that like
uh i mean it's amazing like uh just
looking at my own personal instagram
i've been working on the game for 10
years now i i started to play the game
when i was 10 years old
uh if you told 10 year old me that i
would be sitting here today i wouldn't
have believed it i'm going to copy that
you told 10 year old me i'd be sat here
talking to you about it i i'd weep and i
wouldn't believe it but i'd probably
ignore you and keep playing
and that's and that's the beauty about
it like that the community is so large
so vibrant so active yeah yeah uh it's
it's just it's just amazing it really is
yeah yeah it's such a treat um so what
we're gonna do is gonna talk a little
bit now about looking ahead new stuff
like that uh and how these civilizations
are introduced so you're dealing with
ancient armies and deciding which ones
to add to the game and so i'd love to
know a little bit more about what the
process is on deciding which one you're
going to go for and how to keep it
historically correct and authentic
because i know that's something you guys
really really care about yeah yeah so uh
let's let's take the millions as an
example also uh first thing you do is
you go to the library and you go to the
section of western african history you
take anything you can yeah and you all
become bookworms yeah basically you
start reading you start reading you
start picking a part like the facts uh
the the military battles
interesting things that happened
interesting buildings and changing
military tactics that they employed they
just put everything together and from
that you start to distill gameplay and
think like oh hey we talked about a
hunter woman yeah we can do something
with that uh-huh we can do something
with that uh and like that you kind of
just evolve it
uh you have your design you put it in
the game uh and at that point you kind
of want to see like hey what do i have
here is this still a bit authentic is it
still a bit real uh and we talk a lot to
uh experts in the fields like we're not
going to say that we're experts in mali
and history not at all or enthusiasts
in history yes
and we love what we're doing but we need
to have a pro voice in there that says
like hey what you're doing is that
actually still a bit accurate are you
still representing malian culture in the
way that the voices answer that for you
is it researchers historians
universities we get in touch with
universities we got in touch with uh uh
experts likes you there are people who
specialize in uh weaponry of western
africa yeah well you can talk about to
those people about these specific
weapons uh but more practically like for
example the languages that we have in
the game uh if you play as the malians
you start in the dark age
they speak their ancient malian language
but as you advance through the ages they
speak more and more modern languages
that's a dedication to authenticity that
i truly respect it is amazing it feels
good to just like feel your empire
evolve as you're playing yes yes but
again i don't speak malian we need to go
with you you need to ask them what he
does exactly exactly and that's kind of
the balance we try to find yeah because
in the end it's still a video game right
yes it is a video game it needs to be
fun but we want to make sure that the
civilizations that are in the game are
represented in a way that is respectful
absolutely yeah especially when you give
that back to a community the community
and i'd love to talk to them a little
bit now because the i've seen how
personally committed they are myself
included i'm part of a group called the
court of ages which is a bunch of women
who like to play and test and it's just
the most wholesome place ever um and i'm
curious to know how the age of empires
community have actually impacted or
helped age four along the way uh
uh good to know yes
loads let's keep it like that
so for the longest time the age of
empires community has been involved with
uh development like hey do you like this
here's a beta here's an alpha version
let's play let's develop let's give
feedback and let's build the game that
we all want to play in the end
and that also continues today like we
have the age uh age vampires insiders
you can go to agentvapors.com sign up as
an insider and just register for future
betas uh you can go to the age of
empires forums like all the developers
are there
we we talk there a lot on the forums uh
and just like yeah we have pro console
we have other councils we have so many
groups of players that just provide
feedback and yeah we work with everybody
to try and make and uh yeah bring the
best into age of empires amazing and i
feel like i need i need to be the voice
of the community here and i feel like i
have to ask you we know about the
addition of the ottomans and the malians
can you maybe give us a hint about maybe
any upcoming ancient civilizations that
might be added i've got to try but yeah
that's right yeah cheeky
so uh first of all age of empires is of
course more than civilizations we have
more maps coming more features yeah yeah
that's or that is coming later as well
with this new civilization
uh i can't say more than that but all i
can say asia vampires is alive
and uh yes alive well and thriving yes
absolutely absolutely so i will do that
and say with it being alive and well are
there any events or updates coming up
that we can look forward to instead
uh yes so uh
first of all uh
just to rephrase the 25th of october the
ottomans and the malians will be coming
for free
keyword free free wow okay
to age of empires for so if you have
bought age vampires for in the past on
any platform you will get the news two
civilizations for free and does that
include game pass as well yes that
includes gamepad oh my goodness i love
this conversation everybody gets the new
civilizations yes uh speaking about
things that are for free yep uh right
now at this very moment you can play h54
for free on steam wow okay so if you
were ever on the fence like hey will i
like that game go try it out go to steam
why not go to age of empires for you can
try it out
everything is unlocked you can play the
whole game uh-huh uh till the 29th of
october yeah october august 29th sorry
sorry sorry yes it happens we're live
it's fine there's a lot of dates
there we go
uh so you can try it for free and if you
like to buy it and later it's now uh for
sale on sale as well fifty percent off
on both the microstore and steam so
can pick it up as well opportunity um
i'm really looking forward to all of
those i'm curious though as i've been
walking around gamescom i've been seeing
loads of people repping age of empires
swag yes um is there anything that you
want to maybe showcase what's available
online or maybe for folks while they're
here well we have we have one more
announcement and then it's probably
going to be the least sexy thing that we
will see in this boat broke out
it'll be great there we go
so we're gonna unbutton a bit and we're
gonna show oh yes we are going to be
celebrating uh 25 years of age of
empires uh later this year so the 25th
october yeah it's been 25 years since
the original release 5 25. we're gonna
be celebrating with all the games in the
franchise everybody's invited and uh
yeah it's gonna be lovely it's gonna be
an online global event there will be
more announcements uh so i would say as
as a developer but also as a fan like
you you want to tune in you don't want
to miss it and you've got your twitter
your age of empires to find out more
information websites
exactly uh just look age vampires on any
social media you'll be uh definitely
kept up to date amazing i'm also curious
um i shared a picture on my twitter last
night i mentioned i was at gamescom
there's some red bulls around are you up
to something with red bull at the moment
uh yes we are yes we are so uh red bull
uh wallolo uh legacy is coming up it's
uh it's a big tournament uh where we're
covering hvac one two and four uh-huh uh
and we also will end of october that
will culminate in the large finals in a
castle here in germany that's
that's pretty cool i do have to ask
though are we playing the game or is it
just people going wall or law and seeing
who does it best we we are playing the
game but i definitely want that to be a
tiebreaker or something uh we need to
have it in there as well just add some
spice you know i i'd like to see that
i'd like to see that so yeah the best
players in the world all gathering
together in a german castle here playing
age of empires
for many it's it's childhood dreaming it
sounds like
true honestly and i have got to ask the
shirt is it's catching the light so well
right now i do need my own version is
there a way for folks to get their hand
on that shirt yes this shirt is
available on the xbox gear shop as well
uh alongside a lot of other agent
vampires t-shirts and merchandising so a
lot to pick up there amazing i know what
i'm doing next right but it's been
phenomenal to have you here i've loved
talking to you and of course everyone
else who's tuned in today that is the
end of the show uh so for any segments
you might have missed from today's live
show or for those who just want to
relive today i know i certainly do uh
you can go back and watch the full show
on twitch or youtube and keep the
conversation going using the hashtag
xboxgamescom on social but that is it
for me this is the end of our epic
livestream here from the xbox booth at
gamescom this has been so much fun but
maxine graham let's close this out
[Applause]
all right everyone it has been such a
pleasure being back at gamescom with you
this year surrounded by these amazing
xbox fans and community and of course
you maxie
so now we're too to be signing out from
cologne germany we'll see you next time
bye
you